BRING THIS TO A MEETING OF THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. TO ORDER- I
WILL HAVE A SECRETARY CALLED THE
ROLL WHEN I THINK WE HAVE A CORE
OF THIS POINT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM- BUT BEFORE WE START
TODAY I JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE
SOMEONE SOFIA KWON KIM RAISE
YOUR HAND SURVEYS SAYS YOU KNOW
WE ALL KNOW YOU- THE MIGHTY
SOPHIA- I FIRST MET HER WHAT
CLOSE TO EIGHT YEARS AGO WHEN I
FIRST WALKED INTO. NEWLY ELECTED
THE ASSEMBLY AND SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE THEY THEY CAN BE
BE COMMITTEE TEAM AND ACTUALLY
GREAT JOB OVER THERE SHE IS THE
CHIEF SCHOOL FACILITIES EXPERT
IN HOUSE IN THE CAPITAL GO
NOWHERE ELSE. OKAY OF BUT MORE
THAN THAT SHE'S A GOOD PERSON
SHE'S KIND SHE'S CARING. GOOD
MOTHER ARE SHE'S VERY VERY GOOD
TO THIS COMMITTEE THIS EDUCATION
COMMITTEE VERY GOOD I SHE GETS
THE BIG PICTURE STUFF SHE THEN
AFTER WORKING WITH HER ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR IF YOUR
BACKUP NOT EVEN THAT. A YEAR AND
A HALF SLID OVER TO BE MY CHIEF
OF STAFF AND HAS BEEN VERY GOOD
TO ME VERY GOOD TO MY DISTRICT
VERY GOOD TO MY FAMILY. VERY
GOOD ALL THE STAFF IN IN IN MY
OFFICE AND MANY NOT MANY A FEW
OF THEM WE HAVE RALLIED ACTUALLY
KEEP PEOPLE IN MY OFFICE RIGHT
BUT THOSE WHO HAVE GONE OF MOVED
UP THEY MOVED UP THE LADDER.
BECAUSE OF THE SKILLS SHE'S
INSTILLED THEM AND THE REALLY
THE GOOD BASS THEY SHE GIVES US
STAFF TO THEN GO FLY ON THEIR
OWN. SO I APPRECIATE YOU FOR
HELPING ME I APPRECIATE YOU FOR
HELPING OTHERS AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ANOTHER CHIEF OF
STAFF MR FUNG'S OFFICE. WHOSE
NEW REMEMBER GREAT GUY FROM LA
SHE'S GONNA DO A GREAT JOB
THERE. BUT AS I KINDA START MY
TRANSITION OUT SOME OF THE STAFF
ISN'T GONNA LOOK FOR OTHER
OPTION THEY SHOULD THEY SHOULD
DO THAT- SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THAT I JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK YOU SOPHIA YOU'VE BEEN
VERY GOOD TO ME. AND ALL YOU'VE
DONE FOR ME AND ALL YOU'VE DONE
FOR ALL THE EFFORTS IN THISROOM
TODAY SO GIVE HER ANOTHER ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR SOFTWARE. AND
SHE'S TOUGH. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN CRY. CANADA'S DRUG WHICH IS
REAL TOUGH AB AND SHE WILL
ALWAYS HELP WITH YOU ANY OF YOUR
ISSUES. EDUCATED REAL EDUCATED
READ THE RELATED AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT ARM LET'S
MOVE UNDER COMMITTEE AND IN THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US. I
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO BILLS ON FILE
TODAY TWO BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED
THOSE MEASURES ARE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN. AND THAT'S BY MISTER
BLOOM. A TO A B. TWO SIX THREE
EIGHT AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO. THAT'S WHY MR CHEN
AB TWENTY FOUR TEN SO THOSE
DRIVEN FOLDER FOR MEASURES ON
CONSENT. THE MEASURES ON CONSENT
ARE AS FOLLOWS AB NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE WITH A
MOMENT AB TWENTY FIVE ZERO ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS. THOSE AGAIN ARE
ON CONSENT. PLEASE NOTE THEY'LL
BE HEARING- BILLS AND FILE ORDER
THEY'LL BE NO PHONES TODAY IT'S
ALL IN HOUSE. SCHOOLS ARE OPEN
TEACHERS ARE BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM STUDENTS ARE BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM THEREFORE. ARE THE
ASSEMBLY SHOULD BE AS WELL THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL. SAW ONE NOTE
FOR MEMBERS. FUTURE BAD WHEN
USING THAT BACK DOOR THE ALARM
WILL GO OFF. IF YOU. MAKE THE
ALARM GO OFF YOU HAVE TO BUY
EVERYONE DINNER. SO AS THE RULE.
BUT YOU THE CHAIR ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT. WE WILL PROCEED TO OUR
FIRST ITEM AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA I SAW HER OUT THERE
SHE IS- FOR THIS ITEM WE WILL
HAVE A SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETATION. AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY AND WHEN YOUR
INTERPRETER. MAY COME FORWARD.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MAY COME UP AND SIT IN THE
FRONT. THE WITNESSES THERE ARE
TWO WITNESSES FOR EACH BILL TO
WITNESSES ONLY. BORN AGAINST TWO
OF EACH AND THEY HAVE TWO
MINUTES MAX A AFTER TWO I DO
HAVE TO. MOVE ON SO JUST KNOW
THAT PLEASE PLEASE DO NOT GO
OVER THE TWO MINUTES. AS HAS
BEEN A YEAR OF INSTRUCTORS WITH
THAT ARE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. AGAIN IT'S AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. GOOD AFTERNOON. I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT TANYA
LIEBERMAN FOR WORKING HARD WITH
MY STAFF AND THE SPONSORS ON
THIS BILL LIKE SEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE WOULD
FUND AND ENSURE MUCH NEEDED
EARLY INTENSIVE LANGUAGE
SERVICES FOR DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING CHILDREN OF AGES ZERO
THROUGH FIVE. AS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS I KNOW HOW VITAL THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF A CHILD'S LIFE IS
NOT ONLY IN THEIR PHYSICAL
MENTAL EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO IN LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION. THIS IS WHY
RESOURCES AND SERVICES NEED TO
BE PROVIDED AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE
AND A CHILD'S LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT. CALIFORNIA HAS
COMPREHENSIVE AND COORDINATED
SYSTEM THROUGH THE STATE'S
NEWBORN HEARING SCREENING
PROGRAM WHICH INFANTS. BEFORE
THEY LEAVE THE HOSPITAL. GO
THROUGH THIS ALLOWS US TO
IDENTIFY THE TWO OUT OF TWO TO
THREE OUT OF EVERY THOUSAND
INFANTS WHO ARE BORN DEAF OR
HARD OF HEARING THIS POWERFUL TO
OVERLY DETECTION ALLOWS THE
FAMILY AND THEIR LOCAL OR EARLY
INTERVENTION PROVIDER TO DEVELOP
AN INDIVIDUALIZED FAMILY SERVICE
PLAN IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AT THE EARLIEST AGE.
LANGUAGE ACQUISITION FOR DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
REQUIRE FULL ACCESS AND EXPOSURE
TO LANGUAGE STARTING AT BIRTH
AND CONTINUING THROUGH AGE FIVE
IN ONE OR BOTH LANGUAGES
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE AND
ENGLISH. AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FOUR ONE REQUIRES FUNDING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR CONTRACTING
WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FOR THE
DEAF OR NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED. TO
NOT NON PUBLIC NON SECTARIAN
SCHOOLS OR AGENCIES FOR PURPOSE
OF PROVIDING SPECIALIZED
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AGAIN FROM
BIRTH TO FIVE. HAVING A STRONG
LAO LANGUAGE FOUNDATION WILL
EMPOWER DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN'S TO SUCCEED AND
KINDERGARTEN AND THROUGHOUT
THEIR ACADEMIC YEARS WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OUR MISSIONARY FARINA CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGIATE
COALITION OF AGENCIES SERVING
THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING.
AND THE SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY ONE AND MISS JULIE
RAMS THE MORROW SO MARIO BOARD A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS OF THE DEAF AND SITS
ON THE CAL ADDS LEGISLATIVE.
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. WITH THAT
YOUR FIRST WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE MY GUESS ON IF YOU CAN
HEAR MY INTERPRETER. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR. I AM SHERRY
FARINA I IN THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF AGENCIES
SERVING THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COLLECTIVE GROUP OF A LONG LIST
OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE AND
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL- WE
REPRESENT. THE AND I REPRESENT
THE FULL REPRESENTATION OF DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING- CHILDREN.
IN CALIFORNIA. WE ALL OF US HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS ESPECIALLY INCLUDING THE
PASSAGE OF SB TWO TEN. THAT WAS
IN CHAPTER TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IT
BROUGHT THE STATE'S FOCUS ON
ACCESS TO LANGUAGE FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
AGES ZERO TO FIVE. THIS BILL AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE. WE'LL
KEEP THE STATE'S FOCUS ON IT AND
THE ONLY PROVEN FACT THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING TO BE READY TO LEARN
THEY ABSOLUTELY MUST HAVE ACCESS
TO LEARNING LANGUAGE. BECAUSE OF
LANGUAGE DEPRIVATION EPIDEMIC
DEAF CHILDREN MAY ARRIVE TO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH ZERO
LANGUAGE OFTENTIMES. DURING THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL CONTACT
OUR AGENCIES REQUESTING HELP AND
SUPPORT FOR SERVICES SUCH AS
DEAF COACHING WORKING WITH
FAMILIES AND THEIR INFANTS AND
CHILDREN. HOWEVER NOT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE THIS FUNDING TO
DO THAT. AND ALSO WHEN A CHILD.
IS TRANSITIONING FROM I. F. S.
B. TO AN I EP. OFTEN TIMES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL SAY NO
SORRY WE HAVE NO MONEY TO
PROVIDE SERVICES SO THAT CHILD
THEN OR ANY PROGRESS THAT CHILD
HAD BENEFITTED FROM THE FIRST
THREE YEARS IS NOW LOST UNTIL
THEY ARRIVE TO CANNING GARDEN.
AND THERE IS NOTHING NO
COMMUNICATION. TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THEIR ACADEMICS SO THE
CHILD'S PROGRESS OBVIOUSLY. GOES
DOWN. AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE
WELL CORRECT AN IMBALANCE OF THE
EARLY LANGUAGE ACQUISITION AND
PREPARES DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING CHILDREN TO BE READY TO
LEARN WHEN THEY ARRIVE TO
KIDDING GARDEN. THE BOTTOM LINE
IS KEY LANGUAGE ACCESS. THAT IS
THE BASIC HUMAN RIGHT. FOR DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
DESERVE MANY SERVICES AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT THEY CAN BE
CAUGHT UP IN REQUIRED LANGUAGE.
SO THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO BE
READY TO LEARN AND BE EDUCATED
THERE ARE SCHOOL SYSTEMS SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT TO
AB TWENTY FOUR FIVE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DR JULIE
RAIMES THE MARIO I'M THE CHAIR
FOR LEGISLATIVE CHAIRS FROM CAL
AT WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS FOR THE DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA. I ASKED YOU TO
SUPPORT TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ESSENTIAL
INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR OUR
YOUNG DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE TO
ENSURE LANGUAGE ACQUISITION AND
THEIR DEVELOPMENT. IT IS A VERY
COMMON MISCONCEPTION THAT WHEN.
THE DEAF CHILD WHO IS RECEIVING
SERVICES IS FINE BUT THAT'S NOT
TRUE THEY'RE NOT DOING FINE FINE
IS SAID A DIRTY FOUR LETTER WORD
THEY'RE NOT DOING OKAY WITHOUT
LANGUAGE THERE IS NO BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT THERE'S NO
COMMUNICATION THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN. THERE
ARE NO ABILITY TO SUCCEED. SO
ALL THE STUDIES THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ALL THE DATA
AT THE STATE. IT SHOWS THAT THE
BRAIN IS NOT SIMPLY PICKING UP
LANGUAGE AND COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT. SPECIALIZE IN
SERVICES NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE CHILD AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE
FROM AGES ZERO TO FIVE
OFTENTIMES SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO
NOT TO PAY FOR THE NECESSARY
CRITICAL LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
DAHLE SERVICES. AND THIS IS A
REFLECTIVE IN OUR STATE DATA
REPORTS. ACCORDING TO THE L. A.
REPORT STUDENTS OUTCOMES FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL DECADES. SHOWS THAT
DEVON HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
ARE THE VERY LOWEST PERFORMING
GROUP. AB THEIR PROFICIENCY
LEVEL IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEIR
DEATH. IT IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
MISSING THE CRITICAL WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY OF LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT AND ACQUISITION THIS
GAP IS HUGE AND IT HURTS THE
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN DEVELOPMENT IN ALL
AREAS BY THE TIME THEY ARRIVED
TO KENNY GARDEN. THEY'RE NOT
READY TO LEARN. THEY STRUGGLE
BECAUSE THEY WERE LANGUAGE
DEPRIVED AS MENTIONED EARLIER
FROM MISSOURI FARINA AND
ACCORDING TO S. B. TWO TEN DATA
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN ARE FALLING BEHIND WITH
THEIR EARLY LANGUAGE MILESTONES
AT AGE THREE. AT AGE FIVE THEY
ALREADY HAVE NOT BEEN READY TO
READ AND WRITE WHEN THEY GET TO
KINDERGARTEN. HOWEVER IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT ALL
THE DATA SHOWS THAT DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN WHO
HAVE RECEIVED CONSISTENT AND
PROPER SERVICES TO ACCESS
LANGUAGE FROM ZERO TO FIVE ARE
SUCCEEDING IN SCHOOL CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS WHO WORK WITH DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN NEED
MORE SUPPORT. FROM EXTERNAL
LANGUAGE AND EDUCATION EXPERTS
SO PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU WELL AS I DO WE HAVE A-
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. HE'S
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I
AM NANCY SAGER I'M FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AT- FAMILIES FOR
HANDS AND VOICES I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPORT. ITSELF. HELLO LARA
CAPELLO REPRESENTING CHECHEN-
SACRAMENTO JOHN TRACY CENTER
WEINGARTEN CHILDREN'S CENTER AND
THE CENTER FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION AND DEAFNESS ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS TERESA KNOLL I AM A PARENT OF
A YOUNG MAN WHO IS DEAF WITH
ADDITIONAL DISABILITIES. I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
CHELSEA RAMBLER I HAVE FRIENDS
IN THE DEAF COMMUNITY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK. HELLO
CHAIR MEMBER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HUGH LEFFLER
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF THE DEAF AND I'M
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWO
FIVE FOUR ONE THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS SECTIONAL CAMPOS I'M
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
SACRAMENTO BLACK BLACK DEAF
ADVOCATES WE SERVE THIRTY
COUNTIES IN NORTH CALIFORNIA
WE'RE HERE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MEDINA I
HAVE A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE
DEAF IN MY DISTRICT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THAT'S AGREE I DO ANY
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SEEING NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR. AND
THOSE TESTIFYING TODAY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS EFFORT TO
BETTER SERVE- OUR OUR YOUNGER
STUDENTS THAT ARE DEAF AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT I THINK YOU WOULD
AGREE WE WENT OUT TO. WE WENT
OUT TO THE FREMONT SCHOOL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF
AND I WAS ON MY MORE POWERFUL
EXPERIENCES OF THE OF MY
LEGISLATIVE CAREER QUITE FRANKLY
BECAUSE TELL YOU WHAT. I LEARNED
WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO BE A
MINORITY RIGHT BECAUSE- NOW I
WITH YOU AND I WERE THERE ANYONE
ELSE WAS TALKING AROUND US YOU
KNOW USE AND SIGNING CENTER. AND
WHILE IT'S PRETTY POWERFUL
EXPERIENCE GREAT EXPERIENCE BY
GRAND THEY DO A GREAT JOB
THEY'RE GREAT KIDS. GREAT
PROGRAM. BUT IT WAS VERY
POWERFUL TO GO OUT TO THE ANYONE
EVER GETS A CHANCE TO GO OUT
THERE AND- EXPERIENCE THAT
PROGRAM YOU SHOULD TAKE IT IS
ONE AND RIVERSIDE TO. IN A
MISTER MEDINA SISTER HAS HE'S
JUST STAYED WITH THAT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. THE VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL I'D BE HONORED TO
BE A CO AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD ADD
ME PLEASE FIRST AND COMING FROM
A FAMILY. OF- FAMILY MEMBERS TO.
OUR OLDEST SON OUR MIDDLE SON WE
DIDN'T FIND OUT HE WAS SIXTY
PERCENT. LOSS IN HIS ARM LEFT%
EAR UNTIL THE EIGHTH GRADE. SO
EARLY PREVENTION IS SO
IMPORTANT. AND I KNOW MY NEPHEW
ALSO UNTIL HE STARTED
KINDERGARTEN. THEY DID NOT KNOW
THAT. THE SEVERITY OF HIS
HEARING LOSS BECAUSE YOU READ
LIPS. PRETTY AMAZING HOW YOU
ADDRESSED. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. ANY
FURTHER COMMENT FOR THE
COMMITTEE. A FEELING HERE HIDING
OVER THERE. I'M ON A DIFFERENT
LATER THAN YOUR I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING
THIS BILL IMPORTANT BILL FORD
ENORMOUS OLD SO THANK YOU FOR
DEMONSTRATING YOUR INCLUSIVITY
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS I MEAN NOT
EVERY BILL WE ACTUALLY GET ASL
INTERPRETATION SO HOPEFULLY IT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
FOR EVERYTHING IS WE NEED TO
REALLY INCLUSIVE IN ALL OF OUR
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS AND THAT'S
A REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
EFFORTS IN THIS AND- HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL. IS REMOVED AND WE
ARE SECOND ESTADO THE VICE CHAIR
SECONDS- WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO JOINED US
TODAY AND IF I COULD JUST DO A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE MY
STAFF MEMBER DON ADLER. ACTUALLY
IS IN THE- WORKS WITH THE DEAF
COMMUNITY BROUGHT US TO THIS AND
HAS BEEN. EXCEPTIONAL WITH THIS
COMMITTEE DOING SIGNING HERSELF
. BERGERON- DON OKAY SHE SAID
SHE'S NOT WANTING TO BE
RECOGNIZED BUT WITH THAT- I URGE
. A VOTE AND THANK YOU GRANT I
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE A QUORUM THAT'S RIGHT WE
DON'T OF CORN AND I APOLOGIZE SO
WHEN A QUORUM DOES EXIST WE WILL
. WE HAVE FOUR OKAY I'M SORRY.
CHECK YOUR CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. DONALD HERE
THE DONALD PRESENT VALLEY.
VALLEY PRESENT BENNETT. SENATE
PRESIDENT CHEN CHEN PRESENTLY.
LEAVE PRESENT MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA OKAY MCCARTY
PRESENTS MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA
RIGHT HERE BURKE SILVA PRESENTS
. THEY SAID ASM SO WE DO HAVE A
CORNER STYLE MUCH SO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A. B.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE. FILE ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS. IF YOU DO ACCEPT THE
MEMBERS CORRECT YES OKAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
DONNA HI DALLI DALLI I. BENNETT.
BENNETT I CHEN CHEN I'D LEAVE.
LEAVE I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA AYE QUIRK-SILVA AYE
. THE BILL HAS SOME VOTERS OUT.
THANK YOU TO YOU ANNA SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL WE'RE NOW GOING TO A
- YOU'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO FILED UNDER TO AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO BY. OF THE
FUNKY JOSE MEDINA MR MEDINA COME
FORWARD.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO
A BILL THAT CODIFIES THE RECENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S LEGAL OPINION
. THAT AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OR
EMPLOYEE OF A CHARTER SCHOOL MAY
NOT SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION IN THE
COUNTY WHERE THEY'RE EMPLOYED
SCHOOL IS LOCATED. EXISTING LAW
PROHIBITS AN EMPLOYEE OF A
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM BEING
ELECTED OR APPOINTED MEMBER OF
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT'S GOVERNING
BOARD. UNLESS AND UNTIL THEY
RESIGNED AS A EMPLOYEE. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL ALSO
APPLY THAT SAME LIMITATION TO
ANY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CHARTER
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES CONSERVING ON
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS AUTHORIZING
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S GOVERNING
BOARD. BUT PROVIDING A PROCESS
FOR THE IMPACTED SITTING BOARD
MEMBERS TO FINISH THEIR
RESPECTIVE TERMS OF OFFICE THIS
BILL IS A SIMPLE SOLUTION TO
ENSURE FAIR AND DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
TWO WILL PREVENT ANY CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST AND ESTABLISH
EQUALITY BETWEEN CHARTER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AND TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO I HAVE A
STATEMENT THAT I'D LIKE TO READ
ON BEHALF OF CLEAR CRAWFORD
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR- IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST WHO IS NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE THE DESCENT. THE
TESTIFIED. SO THIS IS A
STATEMENT FROM CLAIRE CRAWFORD
OF IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST. WHICH
IS CONDUCTED EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
ON THE CHARTER SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
OVERALL PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE GENERAL DIRECTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN TO
RECOGNIZE THAT HAVE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS MUST OPERATE
WITH THE SAME TRANSPARENCY
FAIRNESS OPENNESS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. YET THIS SO FAR
HAS NOT BEEN ENFORCED FOR
CHARTER SCHOOL EMPLOYEES TWO
RECENT EXAMPLES SHOW THE NEED TO
CLARIFY PUBLIC INTEGRITY LOTS. A
NEW CHARTER PETITION RECENTLY
PROPOSED BY THE PACIFIC
CHARTERED INSTITUTE CHANGE THE
FOLSOM CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WAS DENIED. LEAVING THE
CHARTER SCHOOL WITH THE OPTION
TO APPEAL THE DECISION THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. YET THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC
CHARTERED INSTITUTE SITS ON THE
SACRAMENTO BOARD OF EDUCATION.
SACRAMENTO SUPERINTENDENT ALSO
EVALUATES THE MERITS OF THE
CHARTER PETITION OF THE COUNTY
BOARD. THE SECOND SITUATION IS
THE CASE OF THE M. INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL CHAIN THAT. THE
APPOINTED SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT JOINED SEVEN
OTHER COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS AND
CALLING FOR AN AUDIT OF THE INS
SPIRED CHARTER CHANGE. HAD THERE
BEEN MEMBERS OF THE COUNTY BOARD
AFFILIATED WITH THE INSPIRED
CHARTER CHANGE THEY COULD HAVE
HAD A SIGNET SIGNIFICANT
CHILLING EFFECT ON THE APPOINTED
. COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT. UNTIL
THE TIME WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS AND ALLOWING- MEMBERS
OF- TEACHERS OR EMPLOYEES OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO CHARTER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES IN PARTICULAR THEIR
LEADERSHIP SHOULD BE COVERED N
THE SAME MANNER AS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES REGARDING
PUBLIC INTEGRITY LOS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR MEDINA YOU READ
OFF ONE WITNESS STATEMENT DID
YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS I WAS
AGED ONE WITNESS I THINK THIS IS
THE ONLY WITNESS UNDERSTOOD
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. ASCENA OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR ANY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR MCCARTY
. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER
BENNETT. SECOND BY MISTER LEE.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO. THIS NOTE
THAT MR MEDINA THIS IS I THINK
AN APPROPRIATE BILL OF GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL AND YOU KNOW WE
WENT THROUGH SOME CHARTER ISSUES
A FEW YEARS AGO I THINK HAD SOME
FAIR LEGISLATION AND A LED BY.
THE CHAIR AND WE WERE ON THESE
ON THESE BILLS THIS ISN'T THAT
YOU KNOW OUR YOU KNOW RE HASHING
THE CHARTER WARS THIS IS ABOUT
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND ONE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT BILLS THAT WE
PASSED WAS FIFTEEN OH FIVE IT
SAYS THAT THE BOARD SHOULD LOOK
AT THE OVERALL. FISCAL HEALTH OF
THE UNDERLYING SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT HE SAID SOMEBODY ON THE
BOARD WHO HAS THAT ANOTHER
AGENDA- THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB. AND SO I THINK THIS
IS PARAMOUNT THAT WE HAVE YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE WE HAVE FAIRNESS
AND TRANSPARENCY IN THIS IS A
SPOT ON MEASURES OF THANK YOU.
WELL SAID MR MCCARTY ANY OTHER.
AMBER'S COMMITTEE WE STILL TIME
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. AMENDMENTS ARE NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR- DONALD HI DONALD I DALLI
DALLI I'D THAT IT. SENATE I'D
CHEN. CAN I LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA. THE
BILL HAS EXPOSED ZERO IT IS OUT
MISTER MEDINA THANK YOU SO GONNA
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE BY MR
BERMAN THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND
PROCEED WHEN READING. AND IF YOU
HAVE WITNESSES THEY MAY COME
FORWARD AS WELL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBING THE ANALYSIS. OUR
SOCIETY HAS WITNESSED PROFOUND
CHANGES IN THE WAYS WE LIVE AND
WORK YOU TO ADVANCES IN
COMPUTER. COMPUTER SCIENCE IS
TRANSFORMING INDUSTRY BOLSTERING
PRODUCTIVITY AND DRIVING JOB
CREATION INNOVATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. DESPITE
GROWING RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES ARE ONLY TAUGHT IN 41%
OF CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS WITH
JUST THREE PERCENT. OF THE ONE
POINT NINE MILLION HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THESE
CRITICAL COURSES. THE PRIMARY
REASON SCHOOLS DON'T OFFER
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
TEACHERS TRAINED TO TEACH THOSE
COURSES. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE
WOULD TAKE AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ENSURING ALL STUDENTS CAN ACCESS
COMPUTER SCIENCE. BOB BY
PREPARING FUTURE TEACHERS TO
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE AN INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO DEVELOP OR
EXPAND K. THROUGH TWELVE
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
COMPUTATIONAL THINKING COURSE
WORK. IN TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THREE- AND WITH ME TODAY ARE
ALEXIS HERE AGAIN REPRESENTING
CO DOT ORG THE BILL SPONSOR. AND
LEE SAID NICK NICK. NICK NICK
POCKET THE TALKING. ABOUT THE
RIGHT. WITH TECHNET. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS HERE
AGAIN THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT CO
.ORG WE ARE DEDICATED TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN SCHOOLS AND
INCREASING PARTICIPATION BY
YOUNG WOMEN AND STUDENTS FROM
OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS
OUR VISION IS THAT EVERY STUDENT
IN EVERY SCHOOL HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN COMPUTER
SCIENCE AS PART OF THEIR CORE K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION WE
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
CHAMPIONING AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THREE WHICH EXPANDS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PRE SERVICE
TEACHERS TO GAIN ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE TRAINING COURSE
FOR COMPETITOR G. AS WAS
MENTIONED. IN CALIFORNIA ONLY
41% OF PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS
OFTEN. OFFER ANY COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION AT ALL THOSE
SCHOOLS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IN SUBURBAN AND WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES. THE PRIMARY REASONS
SCHOOLS DON'T TEACH AS A LACK OF
TRAIN TEACHERS WERE PREPARED TO
TEACH THIS CRITICAL SUBJECT.
GOING TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
COMPUTER SCIENCE. PRE SERVICE
PIPELINE IS A FOUNDATIONAL
STRATEGY FOR BRINGING COMPUTER
SCIENCE TO OUR SCHOOLS PRE
SERVICE TEACHERS ARE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF EDUCATION LEADERS
IN A POSITION TO TEACH
FOUNDATIONAL COMPUTER SCIENCE
SKILLS FOR A WORK FORCE. THAT
NOW DEMANDS THE SKILLS. MULTIPLE
SUBJECTS SEEKING ELEMENTARY PRE
SERVICE TEACHERS ARE IDEAL
CANDIDATES TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM. AS THEY DON'T NEED A
NEW CREDENTIAL. TO TEACH
COMPUTER SCIENCE BUT RATHER
HAVING FOUNDATIONAL TRAINING
SUFFICIENT TO PREPARE STUDENTS.
IN ORDER TO GIVE STUDENTS ACCESS
EARLIER IN THEIR EDUCATION
JOURNEY ITS CRUDE CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE COURSES
AND STARTING IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. AND WE KNOW STUDENTS WHO
HAVE ACCESS EARLY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GO ON TO STUDY
COMPUTER SCIENCES IN COLLEGE
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
FEMALE STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR. FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
INCLUDES THIS AS A FOUNDATIONAL
RECOMMENDATION TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE EXPANDING. COMPUTER
SCIENCE BY BUILDING UP THE PRE
SERVICE EDUCATION PIPELINE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU TO YOUR
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LI ANY
TARGET I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF TECHNET THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE. AS YOU'RE
ALL WELL AWARE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO SOME OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD. IN ADDITION CALIFORNIANS
OF ALL AGES ARE INCREASINGLY
ACCESSING INFORMATION AND
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER
ONLINE. AS A NATURAL CONSEQUENCE
JOBS IN THE SPACE ARE ALSO
GROWING AND IN HIGH DEMAND.
ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
OPEN COMPUTING RELATED JOBS EACH
MONTH. IN ORDER TO FILL THESE
JOBS WITH A QUALIFIED WORKFORCE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSEWORK.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE
CURRENTLY LESS THAN HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS
EVEN OFFER A COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSE. AND THE PRIMARY REASON
FOR THAT IS A LACK OF TEACHERS
TRAINED TO TEACH THE SUBJECT. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE IS CRITICAL
TO EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS.
INTRODUCING COMPUTER SCIENCE AT
A YOUNG AGE WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS DEVELOP
FOUNDATIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS. IN COMPUTER SCIENCE TO
PREPARE THEM FOR COLLEGE CAREERS
AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. AND WE CAN
ACHIEVE THAT BY INVESTING MORE
INTENTIONALLY AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS.
IN TURN THIS WILL ALSO
STRENGTHEN OUR PIPELINE OF
TALENT INTO COMPUTER SCIENCE
RELATED JOBS. ACROSS OUR STATE
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA SUCH A
LEADER IN INNOVATION AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER SUPPORT. I'M FOR THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. BACK'S PERRY ON
BEHALF OF COLLEGE BOARD AWESOME
SPORT THANK YOU M. BLACKWOOD ON
BEHALF OF SNAP IN SUPPORT. THE
PROGRAMMABLE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA AND READY NATION
IN SUPPORT. KIM JONG ON BEHALF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT
. JESSICA SOCCER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK A
PROJECT CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES REPORT ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. REPORT. MARKUPS
IN CALIFORNIAN FIREMEN OF
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK
VERY MUCH REGRET COMING OUT IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL IT IS
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE THE BIGGER PROBLEM WE HAVE
TODAY IS TO DEFICIENCY OF
GENERAL TECH TECHNOLOGY IN DID
YOU GALES OF OUR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS THE EXPECTED THE
DIGITAL SKILLS EXPECTATIONS OF
POTENTIAL TO OF CREDENTIAL
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
HAVE NOT CHANGED IN TWENTY YEARS
THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE REWORKED
TO INCLUDE SUPPORT THAT IS
NEEDED FOR THE GENERAL DIGITAL
AND TECHNOLOGY SKILL SETS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEEING AFURTHER OPPOSITION ANY
CONSUMMATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL
OF THIS MAY COMMENT I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO HEAR IS BUILD
THE CAPACITY TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY. RIGHT TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE THERE TO HELP STUDENTS
SUCCEED IN A AND THE TECH
TECHNOLOGICAL WORLD WHICH IS A
BIG THING RIGHT THIS ABOUT THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY SO I
APPRECIATE- WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
HERE TODAY A BUILDING THE
PIPELINE URGE YOU TO DO IS
REALLY HOLD AS IT AS THIS GOES
FORWARD A BUDGET PLAN WHAT ARE
THE SIGNS OF BEING YOU WATCH THE
UNIVERSITIES THE COLLEGES
BECAUSE THEY LOVE THE MONEY THEY
DON'T LOVE THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE NEED IS DEFINITELY SEE SOME
OUTPUTS AND WHAT IS THE PRODUCT
THEY'RE PRODUCING WITH THE MONEY. WE GIVE THEM BECAUSE OFTEN
THEY COLLABORATE. THAT'S GREAT.
GREAT BUT YOU DON'T DEVELOP
PROGRAMS RIGHT GET THE MONEY AND
SO THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING
ATTACHED THE MONEY IN THE END I
WOULD HOPE SO PAY ATTENTION TO
THE OPERATE HERE AND- SO WITH
THAT- ANY OTHER. COMMENTS I MAKE
ONE MORE COMMENT THAT IS HAVE TO
MAKE- ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
WE'RE HAVING THE SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW I TALKED TO AN ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT THE OTHER DAY-
AND SHE SAID I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING ON OUT THERE RIGHT. AND
SHE HAS A HARD TO GET CLASSIFIED
STAFF SHOULD ABSOLUTELY THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A CHALLENGE RIGHT
SPECIAL ALWAYS MANAGES TO THE
UNIQUE THING THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. THIS TEACHERS ARE
LEAVING THE TEACHING PROFESSION
MAJOR. CHANGES I'VE NEVER SEEN
THAT BEFORE. USUALLY THEY GO TO
ANOTHER DISTRICT RIGHT. BUT
THEY'RE COMPLETELY LEAVING THE
TEACHING PROFESSION SO YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. WITH A FIVE
POINT 33% COLA. WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE YOUNGER PEOPLE SAY
THAT'S A STARK. WILL CPI'S AND
SEVEN POINT FIVE JURORS IN
PERSON INCREASES OR TWO POINT
THREE. RIGHT THERE ARE ALMOST
TEN RIGHT. THEN YOU ADD ABOUT 4%
COSTS THAT ARE UNIQUE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT COST PRESSURES NON CBI.
DIRECT ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT 85%
JUST STAY STATUS QUO. RIGHT
WOULD LAST YEAR. AND YET THE
MONEY IN THE ROSE BUDGET IS
DRIVING MONEY AWAY FROM THE
CLASSROOM AND ARGUABLY. AT LEAST
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE CREATING A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS WE NEED TO
CERTAINLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
TODAY. BUT AS WE LOOK AS WE-
START TO WORK ON THE BUDGET HELP
YOU'LL PAY. ATTENTION TO THAT-
MISTER ROOM BUT ALSO THOSE WHO
CAME UP AND SPOKE SOME OF
PRIVATE COMPANIES WE NEED YOUR
HELP. TO GET THIS MONEY IN THE
CLASSROOM LOWER SOME CLASS SIZES
BECAUSE THAT SPEAKS TO STUDENT
MENTAL OF. KNOW HOW AND ALSO
TEACHER MENTAL HEALTH. SO
THAT'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
IT. OVERDRESSED REGARDING AND
CHECK MY MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME GET THAT OUT
MISTER BURN I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
TAKE THAT AS MY CLOSE TO HIM THE
RESEARCHERS WRITE THAT IN THE I
KNOW YOU'RE DOLLARS. THE CLOSER
YEAH. FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DONALD. BY
DONALD I DELHI. DELHIITES
BENNETT. BENNETT I CHEN. CAN I
LEAVE LEAI MCCARTY THIRTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THOSE SIX WAS IT IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MR BERMAN NOW GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER- FOR FILE NUMBER
FOUR. WHICH IS- MISS
THREE OF US. OKAY SYRINGA WHO'S
HERE MR FONG HERE WHAT FILE ARE
YOU- NINE SINCE YOU'RE HERE YOU
BETTER GET THE MICROPHONE
REVERSAL WALKS IN. YOU DO IT
YOURS BUT WE'RE WAITING FOR MR
RIVAS. WAITING ALSO FOR MYSTERY
OF US MISS REAVIS- MISTER MATHIS
. AND STOP THEIR STAFF IS
LISTENING OR MOVING FORWARD NO
MOVED TO THE END OF THE LINE MR
FONG YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO ONE FIVE A WOULD REQUIRE THE
GOVERNING BOARD IN BODY MEMBERS
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS. COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE ETHICS
TRAININGS. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
SCHOOL OFFICIALS ARE NOT
EXPRESSLY REQUIRED. TO RECEIVE
SUCH TRAINING AND ETHICS. OVER
THE LAW STILL REQUIRES LOCAL
AGENCY OFFICIALS AS DEFINED. THE
TAKE TRAINING IN ETHICS AT LEAST
EVERY TWO YEARS. SCHOOL
OFFICIALS MAKE A PLETHORA OF
INFORMED DECISIONS I CAN CARRY
OUT THE CO IMPLICATIONS. AS A
FORMER COULD MAKE COLLEGE BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE ALEX MAKE COLLEGE
DISTRICT. A FAMILIAR FOR THE
NEED FOR ETHICS TRAINING. DOES
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE FIVE IT
WOULD REQUIRE A GOVERNING BOARD
AND BODY MEMBER OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT. COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OR CHARTERSCHOOL TO
RECEIVE ETHICS TRAINING TO THE
SAME EXTENT AS A LOCAL AGENCY
OFFICIAL I THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
OUR MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MR FONG WHETHER ANY
MEMBER ANY- PERSONS. ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OKAY SEE
NO OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ANY THE PUBLIC. THE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC NO SEE ANY OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION SEEING
OPPOSITIONAL RING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I DO WE HAVE A MOTION
MR MCCARTY MOVE THIS MCCARTY
MOVES- IN SECOND AYE MR BENNETT
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A QUESTIONS
NO ARE YOU MAY CLOSE MR FONG I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE GERMAN
WITH ASK YOU JUST COMMUTER EACH
COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR THE AYE
BUT- THANK YOU SO MUCH. FILE
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
YOU APPROPRIATIONS THE DONALD
BY. THE DONALD I DALLI. DALLI
I'D SENATE. SENATE I'D CHEN N.
I. LI. LI I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THIS SIX ALSO IT IS
NOT MR FONG THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE TERM. WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO WE'RE WAITING FOR FILE
ITEM REFORMIST RIVAS- WAITING
FOR MR GIPSON. WE'RE NOT WAIT
FOREVER I WAS JUST SALAS. MR
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA. RUBIO.
BALLADARES MISTER LEE MISTER LEE
YOU WANNA PRESENT. AND THEN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE PRESENT WILL GO
TO MISTER MCCARTY AFTER MR LEE.
ARTISTRY BILLS. YOU MISTER LIAM
A MR LEE HAS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FILE UNDER SEVENTEEN IT IS AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. ON. MISTER
LEE'S WEDDING FIRST FOLDER.
SOMEWHERE THERE'S A STAFFER
RUNNING DOWN THE HALL.
SKITTERING DOWN THE HALL. I YOU
KNOW HE DOES MR MCCARTY WOULD
YOU. HE'S PREPARED- SO MR
MCCARTY- FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN FIVE UNDER EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO MR MCCARTY
. YES THREE BILLS. TWENTY TO
THIRTY FIRST THAT WE SENT A
TWENTY TO THIRTY TWO OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON OUR
CLASSROOMS AND PUBLIC HEALTH OF
OUR STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS
ACCORDING THE EPA INDOOR AIR
POLLUTION IS RANKED AS ONE THE
TOP FIVE AND MARK ENVIRONMENT A
WRIST FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS
BILL IMPROVE CLASSROOM AIR
QUALITY AND PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE REQUIRING
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES. TO
CONDUCT COMPREHENSIVE H. FACT
INSPECTIONS ONCE EVERY FIVE
YEARS AND IS IN INSTALL CO TWO
MONITORS IN CLASSROOMS. AGAIN
MAINTAINING GOOD INDOOR AIR
QUALITY IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURING.
THE WEALTH- BEHAVING OF
INDIVIDUALS TO SPEND MANY HOURS
INDOORS I CAN TELL YOU THAT WITH
TWO LITTLE KIDS AND THIS IS A
PARTICULAR CONCERN FOR KIDS WHO
SPEND MANY HOURS IN THE
CLASSROOM SOMETIMES ANTIQUATED-
EQUIPMENT. FOR VENTILATION POOR
INDOOR AIR QUALITY BUT CHILDREN
AT RISK PARTICULARLY GIVEN THEIR
SUSCEPTIBILITY TO ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND FAX IT IS WE SHOWN
THAT UNDER VENTILATION IN
CLASSROOMS CAN CAUSE ADVERSE
EFFECTS ON STUDENT PERFORMANCE
AND CAN IMPACT THEIR COGNITIVE
ABILITIES. THAT'S ARE REQUIRING
THIS APP EFFORTS WILL IMPROVE-
CERTAINLY OUR CLASSROOMS AND
MAKE SURE ALSO THAT WE PROTECT
THE ASSETS OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION SITUATION.
I WITH ME TODAY IS REPRESENT
THEIR FROM THE ST PATRICK'S
COUNCIL SCOTT WHICH IN TIME. USE
THAT WAS SHEET METAL WORKERS
THANK YOU. RESEARCHERS MEMBERS
WHICH ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS. IN THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
PLUMBING AND MECHANICAL
OFFICIALS AND WITH THESE
COMMENTS LOW WHO ALSO TESTIFY.
REALLY QUICKLY MR CHAIRMAN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY A TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY REPORT BY THE UC
DAVIS WESTERN COOLING EFFICIENCY
CENTER AND THE INDOOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP AT LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB. FOUND
THAT OVER HALF OF NEW SCHOOL H.
FAX SYSTEMS HAD SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
INSTALLATION AND A VAST MAJORITY
OF CLASSROOMS IN CALIFORNIA
FAILED TO MEET MINIMUM
VENTILATION RATES. FURTHERMORE
NEARLY 20% OF THE CLASSROOMS
AVERAGE YOUR TWO THOUSAND PARTS
PER MILLION IN CO TWO. WELL OVER
THE ELEVEN HUNDRED PPM MAXIMUM
THAT IS WHAT RECOMMENDED AND
WEALTH IN THE LAKE CLASSROOMS.
COMBINED THESE UNDERPERFORMING
SYSTEMS FAILED ME TAKE GOOD
INDOOR AIR QUALITY AND THEY GET
A DAILY IMPACTS TO HEALTH. IN
ADDITION STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT
BETWEEN 3250% OF NEW H. FAX
SYSTEMS. AND UP 285% OF
REPLACEMENT SYSTEMS ARE
INSTALLED INCORRECTLY LEADING
THE UNDER PERFORMANCE THIS
RESULTS. ACCORDING TO THE CPUC
AND CAL FORTY INTERVIEW
COMMISSION INCREASED ENERGY USE
OF UP TO THIRTY PERCENT- WE
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE. RESULTS
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAME ORGANIZATIONS AND SCOTT
JUST MENTIONED. AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURING THAT
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE EXPECTS
ESTIMATES THAT ARE ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND PROVIDES STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ADEQUATE
VENTILATION. A RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A TOWN STUDY SHOWS
VENTILATION CAN CUT SCHOOL
COVERT CASES BY EIGHTY TWO
PERCENT. AS WE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM MASK IN THE CLASSROOM IT'S
CRITICAL THE TEACHERS AT LEAST
HAVE THE PROTECTION PROVIDED BY
PROPERLY OPERATING VENTILATION
SYSTEMS. CURRENTLY TOTAL IT
REQUIRES ANNUAL INSPECTIONS OF
SCHOOL EXPECTS SYSTEMS BUSES NOT
PROVIDING GUIDANCE AND WHAT THAT
INSPECTION. INCLUDES OR HOOP
WHAT QUALIFICATIONS ARE NEEDED
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO DO THOSE
INSPECTIONS. WHATEVER
INSPECTIONS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
DONE THE STUDY SAID SCOTT JUST
MENTION SHOW THAT THE INSPECTION
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE VENTILATION IN THE
SCHOOLS. AFTER IN A SIXTY TWO
POINT ONE IS A NATIONAL INDUSTRY
STANDARDS SET FORTH ITS FAXES TO
INSPECTION TESTING. REQUIREMENTS
IT RECOMMENDS A COMPREHENSIVE
INSPECTION AND VERIFICATION
EVERY FIVE YEARS THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT SETS FORTH WHAT
THAT WILL INCLUDE DOS REQUIRES
CARBON MONOXIDE SENSORS IN THE
CLASSROOM SO YOU KNOW DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR WE CAN MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ADEQUATE VENTILATION AND
CORRECT ANY. CHANGES IN THE
VENTILATION RATES THAT OCCUR
BECAUSE OF CLASS SIZE OR OTHER
REASONS WE URGE A VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS LIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- S. SEEN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
PRESS THE BUTTON RIGHT THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN DOMINGO AND I SPEAK
TODAY ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
WHERE I SERVE AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS OF WHICH I AM A
DIRECTOR. APSO IS A STATE WIDE
OR ASSOCIATION WITH TWENTY FOUR
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO FOURTEEN
HUNDRED K. THROUGH TWELVE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND ROLLED IN
ROLLING APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN OF THOSE
SCHOOLS ARE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS
LOCATED IN TWELVE DIOCESES AND
ARTS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE
REGARD THE GOALS AND INTENT OF
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THIRTY TWO
AS LAUDABLE WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
TAKE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. TO A MEASURE THAT
WOULD IMPOSE A CRUSHING UNFUNDED
MANDATE UPON THE STATE'S PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. SIGNIFICANT FUNDING HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS
FOR THESE PURPOSES BUT NOT TO
PRIVATE AND RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS.
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWOS
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRIVATE SCHOOLS
DO NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT
ALREADY MANY OVERWHELMINGLY RELY
UPON DEFICIT BUDGETING. AND
AEROBIC FUNDRAISING EFFORTS JUST
TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN. PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE STILL REELING FROM
THE DEVASTATING FINANCIAL IMPACT
OF THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO
MANAGE COSTS IN A HIGHLY
INFLATIONARY ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT. WE NEED TO MARSHAL
WHATEVER ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE
CAN TO ADDRESS LEARNING LOSS AND
REPAIR THE SOCIO EMOTIONAL
DAMAGE INFLICTED UPON OUR
CHILDREN BY THE TRAUMA AND
DESTRUCTION OF THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS. AB DE TO THIRTY TWO MIGHT
BE A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR
SCHOOLS RECEIVING STATE FUNDING
HOWEVER IT IS AN OVERWHELMING
BURDEN TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS
PARTICULARLY THERE IS THOSE
SERVING LOW INCOME POPULATIONS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK TO. MEANT
THAT WHAT. APPLICATION DELTA
PRIVATE AND PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS.
THAT WOULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO. THE
OTHER OPTION OF COURSE WOULD BE
TO FIND THE COST OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL SCHOOLS
INCLUDING PRIVATE AND RELIGIOUS
SCHOOLS THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION CENA
FURTHER OPPOSITION OVER IRAQ AND
THE RAIL I JUST WANT TO START
OFF BY SAYING THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I
KNOW INDOOR OR QUALITY PROBABLY
BETTER THAN MOST I CAN TELL YOU
WHEN YOU HAD THAT ONE PM OUR
YOU'VE ALREADY PROBABLY HAD
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE PLUS
KIDS IN THE ROOM RIGHT. CHANGING
AROUND THE DAY. BUT I MEAN
THAT'S A LOT OF ERROR. A LOT OF
BREATH GOING INTO THE CLASSROOM
AND AS ALWAYS LEAVE THAT
CLASSROOM- I WOULD I WAS THE
KIND OF TO YOUR EYES OUT OF MY
DOOR OPEN AND A FAN BECAUSE I
HAD TO. TURN THAT AIR OR JUST AS
THOSE AFTERNOON HOURS LISTEN YOU
REALLY FEEL IT AS AN ADULT I DID
I CAN TELL YOU. RIGHT AND
IMPACTS THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
BECAUSE IT IMPACTS A STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO PAY ATTENTION READ
THE GET TIRED THOSE ARE THE
PHYSICAL EFFECTS. OF WHAT YOU
WISH TO ADDRESS AVOID SO I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT TO THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL ISSUE- I STRUGGLE
WITH WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM
BECAUSE I THINK. PRIVATE SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO. SHOULD HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF HAVING- CLEANER IN
THE CLASSROOM APPROPRIATE ERROR
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO LABEL IT-
AND IF YOU GO ON AMAZON THESE
THINGS REALLY AREN'T. THAT
EXPENSIVE TO MONITOR. THE AIR.
RIGHT BECAUSE I LOOKED I THOUGHT
ABOUT GETTING ONE FOR MY OWN
CLASSROOM ONE TIME BECAUSE I
WANT TO. CHECK CHECK WITH ALL
THE STUFF MEANT BECAUSE I. YOU
KNOW SINCE THERE WAS A PROBLEM
ON- BUT AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTION I APPRECIATE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE COST IMPLICATIONS EVEN
THOUGH SOME PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE
VERY WELL FUNDED RIGHT. I GET
THE POINT YOUR POINT IS PROBABLY
THAT'S NOT ALL OUR RIGHT- SO I
APPRECIATE. YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WITHOUT ANY OF THE OTHER.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
BENNETT. I DID IT I JUST MIKE MY
QUESTION FOR THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
REPRESENTATIVES. THIS IS JUST IT
IF THE H. FAX SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING PROPERLY AND THE
CHILDREN ARE NOT GETTING GETTING
CLEAN AIR. I ASSUME THAT YOUR
POSITION AS YOU WILL YOU WANT
THAT CORRECTED. WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE THAT CORRECTED YES AND IN
MANY CASES THAT INVOLVES
SIGNIFICANT FUNDRAISING AT THE
LEVEL OF THE SCHOOL- WE AGREE
WITH THE PREMISE OF THIS BILL WE
JUST CANNOT. TAKE ON THAT
OVERWHELMING FINANCIAL BURDEN
BUT IT IS IMPERATIVE TO CORRECT
THAT PROBLEM IF IT EXISTS YES WE
WOULD LIKE TO IF WE CAN'T. AND
THEN THE QUESTION IS JUST HOW
THE PEOPLE FUND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. I'M ANY OTHER.
MR CHEN. THANK YOU GEORGE
JUANITA CLARIFICATION I WANT TO
CLARIFY WHETHER OR NOT THE
AUTHOR WAS TAKING AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD REMOVE THE MANDATE
FOR THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS IS THAT-
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE. A
TAKE TO CONSIDERATION- WELL I
DON'T KNOW THAT TODAY HE'S OPEN
TO THAT HE WOULD HAVE TO APPOINT
- NO AT THIS POINT I'M NOT AND
HERE'S WHY- TWO REASONS YOU KNOW
WE DON'T SEE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S UP HERE. OPPOSING THE
BAIL. BECAUSE I WOULD THINK TO
KNOWING THAT YOUR EQUIPMENT IS
NOT WORKING PROPERLY YOU WANNA
KNOW THAT TOO. BECAUSE YOU'RE
PAYING HIGHER MANY TIMES ENERGY
BILLS ROM. EQUIPMENT IS NOT
PROPERLY. INSTALLED THE FIRST
TIME AS A HEARD FROM OUR
WITNESSES. AND SECONDLY-
QUALITIES ARE QUALITY I KNOW
THAT TWO YEARS AGO. RIGHT HERE
IN MY CITY SACRAMENTO WE HAD THE
WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE WORLD.
FOR THREE STRAIGHT DAYS WHY
BECAUSE FIRES UP THERE UP NORTH
AND SO THE KIDS ARE TOO
DIFFICULT TIME LEARNING AND
FOCUSING. AND HAVING TO BE
RIDICULOUS TO HAVE. ALL THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AB ONE RULES
OTHER HERE BUT LET'S GET THEIR
KIDS ARE KIDS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IS PUBLIC HEALTH SO- WILL BE
WILLING TO LISTEN TO THE ISSUES
BUT I THINK OVERALL. WE DO A LOT
OF THINGS IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CODE RELATES TO ALL SCHOOLS.
THIS IS ONE RIGHT NOW I THINK
ALL SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. UP THERE
HAS BEEN MISTER BENNETT IT IS
JUST ONE OF WHAT TO ECHO THAT
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF MY
QUESTION TO THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS
THAT IS- I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE A SEPARATE SEPARATE
STANDARDS SO I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR- AN EXCEPTION.
IN THIS SITUATION. DOESN'T
ATTRACT ME AS PER. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. MISTER BENNETT THE
SECOND MR LEE- YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AT CHOI THE DISCUSSION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT.
OUR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
DONALD I'VE DONE ALL I VALLEY.
VALUE NO SENATE HI SENATE I CAN
. CAN NOT VOTING. LEAVE THE ICE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY II QUIRK-SILVA
. WELL THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE SO
IT IS OUT MISTER MCCARTY THANK
YOU WELL THAT WILL GO TO RUN
OVER TO MISTER GIBSON MISTER
MCCARTY MISTER GIBSON IF YOU
COME FORWARD YOUR WITNESSES. AND
YOU MAY PERCEIVE THEM READY MR
GIVES IS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWO ZERO THREE EIGHT. BY THE
NUMBER EIGHT.
WHAT IS A THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
SEEKS TO PROVIDE A SOLUTION. UP
WELL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
ACCURATELY ACCURATE COUNT OF
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
BEFORE I BEGIN. I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US. UP TO MAKE
THIS BILL A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THIS COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WOULD
. MAKE THE BILL SPECIFIC TO LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND
WOULD ALSO AT LANGUAGE AROUND
TEACHERS. INCLUDING A SUNSET OF
THREE. YEARS AS WELL AS A- AS
WELL AS SUBMIT AN ANNUAL REPORT
THAT LAYS OUT THE PROGRESS ON IT
MEETINGS RATIO REQUIREMENTS LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
LARGEST- PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS L.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DOES ALSO SERVE
ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION STUDENT BODIES IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA- LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR SCHOOLS. AND 80% OF THOSE
STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DIST RECEIVED A
THREE YEAR WAIVER UNDERSCORE
WAIVER FROM MEETING THE FOR
MEETING THE RATIO REQUIREMENT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE DISTRICT
TO A RECESS LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS COMPLIANCE
THIS WAIVER IS SET TO EXPIRE BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR WHICH WOULD
MEAN THE LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- I MIGHT HAVE TO LAY
OFF. MANY STAFFS- WITHIN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ITSELF THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS SIMPLE. AND THAT
IT IS TO PROVIDE A SOLUTION TO
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
IMPROVING THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND OVERALL ACADEMIC
I'M PROGRESS UP OUR STUDENTS.
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE ALSO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OUR TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS WITH THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES NEEDED TO RECOVER FROM
LEARNING LOSS DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC. AND THEY HAVE DIRECTLY
SUPPORTED OUR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM
JOINING ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE WILL BE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOS ANGELES
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND- THE
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS MILLION VICE
GOODISON WAS SELF INTRODUCED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON HI MY NAME IS MARIA
SORT OF MY YOUR AND I REPRESENT
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS THE DIRECTOR OF
ORGANIZATIONAL EFFECTIVENESS IN
THE OFFICE OF THE DEPUTY CHIEF
OF HUMAN RESOURCES. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH CLARIFIES THE
DEFINITION OF ADMINISTRATOR
INTENDED TO INCLUDE ONLY STAFF
EMPLOYED IN A POSITION REQUIRING
AN ADMINISTRATIVE CERTIFICATION
QUALIFICATION. AND EXAMS LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED FROM COUNTING
MAGNET SCHOOL COORDINATORS
MISCALCULATION SINCE THESE
POSITION SUPPORT COMPLIANCE WITH
A COURT DESEGREGATION ORDER.
THESE ARE ALL TEACHERS UTL A
MEMBERS TEACHERS ON SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT WHO DO NOT SUPERVISE
ANY EMPLOYEES. RED LAW REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MEET A
CERTAIN ADMINISTRATOR TO TEACHER
RATIO ALSO KNOWN AS OUR TO. WITH
THE INTENT THAT RESOURCES ARE
DEDICATED TO CLASSROOM SUPPORTS
AND INSTRUCTION HOWEVER SINCE
THE ENACTMENT OF THE LAW. THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY CHANGES IN
EDUCATION POLICY FUNDING AND IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS APPROACHES TO
SUPPORT THE WHOLE CHILD BY
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE ACADEMIC
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND HEALTH
NEEDS OF EVERY. STUDENT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED RECEIVE A THREE YEAR
WAIVER FROM MEETING THE ARE TWO
REQUIREMENTS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE DISTRICTS TO REASSESS
THE LOCAL PROGRAMS AND MOVE
TOWARDS COMPLIANCE DESPITE THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
POSING UNPRECEDENTED CHANGE
CHALLENGES. FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED STAFF HAS
CONTINUED ITS COMMITMENT TO
EXAMINE EXISTING PROCESSES AND
ANALYZING JOB DESCRIPTIONS
INCLUDING INTERPRETATION OF THE
LAW AS IT RELATES TO OUR
STAFFING NEEDS IN EDUCATING. THE
WHOLE CHILD LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SEEKS A PERMANENT SOLUTION AND
BELIEVES THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS WE ARE PURSUING WOULD
HELP MEET THE OBJECTIVE. WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON IMPROVING UPON THIS LANGUAGE
AS AND ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS
WE INTEND TO HAVE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE SENATE AS
THE BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. FOR THESE
REASONS LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
URGES YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TO THE NEXT WITNESS.
DOUBLE THE SIZE OF MY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE HERE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS OR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ARE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOROTHY JOHNSON AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS PLEASE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HI KATIE HARTMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION BUT HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF AND THAT SPONSORS ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE APPRECIATE THE CAN
SUGGEST A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THEY ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
AND AGREED THAT IT SHOULD BE
LIMITED TO- JUST L. A. U. S. E.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SYRIAN
OPPOSITION OVER YOUR BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES THEIR MOTION. MR
MCCARTY MOVES MISTER BENNETT
SECOND ACTORS I. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAY NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER GIBSON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT
A. B. TWO ZERO THREE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL ACT THE
DONALD HI DELHI. BELLY I'VE DONE
IT HI SENATE I CHEN. FAN I'D LI.
LI I AM MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. IT IS SIX OH TWO AS
A MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT MOVE IS TO GARCIA
COME FORWARD PLEASE ANY OF YOUR
WITNESSES MAY COME FORWARD AS
WELL. WE'RE GING TO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO THREE
TWO THREE SEVEN THREE THAT'S WHY
I'M NUMBER ELEVEN. THEY THANK
YOU MR KARAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AND SO I'LL KEEP THIS
BRIEF I WANT JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE TEAM WHO
HAS PUT FORWARD SOME AMENDMENTS.
THAT THE REALLY HELP US ACHIEVE
OUR GOAL. THIS THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE ADAPTIVE SPORTS
TO A PILOT PROGRAM FOR PURPOSES
OF FUNDING A FIVE YEAR- GRAHAM.
THAT FOCUSES ON PUPILS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. I'M WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
IN YOUR ANALYSIS THAT. LEADS TO-
THE PROVING THAT THE SPORTS
INTEGRATION TO EDUCATION. WITH
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES-
HELPS INCREASE THEIR ABILITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SAYING NO OTHER WITNESSES ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. IN
OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES ARE MOTION. MOVE ON
MR MCCARTY SECOND BY- MEASURES
REALLY- OKAY ADD- COME IS READY
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS- DO YOU
ACCEPT THE MEMBERS YES WE DO
GREAT THANK YOU MAKE CALLS THANK
YOU FIVE EIGHT THREE I WILL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW I'D DALLY. DALLY I'D SENATE
HI SENATE I CHEN. AND I LEAVE.
LEVY I AM MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THE BILL HAS
EXPOSED SERVICE OUT MISTER SALAS
. YOU MAY COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
MISTER SALAS WHICH IS. MISTER
SOLACE IS- THANK YOU- FILE
NUMBER TEN AB TWO THREE FIVE
FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN YOU IF
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT MAY
COME FORWARD RIGHT NOW BUT YOU
MAY PROCEED IN READY FOR IT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS SIDE- FIRST LIKE TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ON A THE AMENDMENTS FOR
THE BILL AND MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD. I AM PROUD PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
FIVE WHICH WILL PROTECT OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS BY
REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO REPORT
CYBER ATTACKS AND TASKING THAT
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER OR IT'S ALSO
KNOWN AS THE S. C. IC I WOULD
TRACKING AND ANALYZING THESE
ATTACKS EARLY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DOES NOT
TRACK CYBERATTACKS SCHOOLS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT ANY CYBER
ATTACKS OR ATTEMPTED. ATTACKS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN SEVEN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WERE VICTIMS OF A SECURITY
BREACH THAT SAW THEIR SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS DATES OF BIRTH
PHONE NUMBERS AND PRIVATE HEALTH
AND INFORMATION STOLEN BY CYBER
CYBER CRIMINALS I ALSO SAW THIS
IN MY OWN DISTRICT IT WITHOUT
HIM OF ONE OF THIS TO DOWN IN
KERN COUNTY AS WELL SO WITH THAT
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A SECOND AND I'LL JUST
KEEP IT SHORT AND ASK
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. AND.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK THEY WERE ON THE
PHONE BUT WE ARE DOING FUND
TESTIMONY PHONES. LASSES OPEN
WERE OPEN- OKAY ANY ANY ANY ANY
OPPOSITION COMPORT ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING OPPOSITIONAL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
COMMENTS READY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE VICE CHAIR PLEASE. HAVE
QUESTIONS SO THIS DOES NOT
INCLUDE COLLEGES CORRECTOR
THAT'S CORRECT HEY DID YOU
CONSIDER INCLUDING COLLEGES
STATE WE DID WE DID BUT- WE'RE
HAPPY TO. RABIL LOOK BACK INTO
THAT TO RE INCLUDING THEM THIS
IS A RE INTRODUCTION OF A BILL
THAT WE DID THAT WAS STOPPED
BECAUSE- OF COVERED PRIOR. THE
LOWER HAPPY TO LOOK AT- KEY
THROUGH FOURTEEN BECAUSE I
BELIEVE FOR THE UC'S BECAUSE OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION CAN
ONLY RECOMMEND THINGS TO. THE
UC'S AND- SEE ISSUES ALSO HAVE
THEIR- CONSTITUTION AS WELL THAT
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH. ACID
TYPICALLY I KNOW WE DO K.
THROUGH FOURTEEN BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE DEFINITELY LOOK
INTO. IN THE MEDIA YOU'VE SEEN
SEVERAL REPORTS OF UNIVERSITIES
HAVING THINGS LEANS OUT AND THEN
A MONTH LATER SOMEONE'S LAID
OFF. BUT IT DOES YOU KNOW EVEN
THE STUDENTS ARE NOTIFIED THAT
THEIR INFORMATION HAS BEEN
LEAKED. SO I THINK IT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA IF THERE'S ANY WAY TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PREACHER THAT. ARE
WITH THAT- NO FURTHER COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU
DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS I DO
YES YOU DO THANK YOU. FOR THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BUT WE DID
HAVE A MOTION I BELIEVE. MR
MCCARTY. MOVED MR THE SECOND.
YES FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE THE DONALD R. O.
DONNELL I'D DALLY DALLY I'D
BENNETT HI SENATE AYE CHAN CHAN
I LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE QUIRK-SILVA. BALLISTICS
ABOUT SODAS OUT MR SALISBURY
THANK YOU MR THINKING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT WILL GO BACK TO MR
MCCARTY- STILL WAITING FOR
MEMBERS TO COME DOWN MR MCCARTY
IS GOING TO PRESENT- FILE ITEM
NINETEEN. TWENTY FOUR OH ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE FIVE AND IN
NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS A- ISSUE THAT YOU ARE
NICE BUT A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT IN OUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAD A DIALOGUE
EARLIER WITH MR BERMAN HIS BILL
ABOUT THE TEACHER SHORTAGE AND
THE WORK WE NEED TO DO TO GET
MORE TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM
ASSEMBLY PUT WE'RE NOT- WE'RE
NOT DOING A GOOD JOB AT KEEPING
UP- CERTAINLY PEOPLE IN THE
PIPELINE BUT ALSO PEOPLE LEAVING
THEIR PROFESSION. THIS WILL HELP
ADDRESS OUR TEACHER SHORTAGE BY
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREP PROGRAMS
THAT OUR CALLS UNIVERSITIES
ACTUALLY DO WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT NO MORE I'M NOT AS
MUCH PLANNING BUT ACTUALLY MORE
DOING OH YES WE DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS FOCUSING ON
THIS ON THIS PIECE I WE DO NOT
WE STARTED THIS A DECADE OR SO
AGO BUT WE REALLY NEED TO STEP
IT UP ACCORDING TO THE LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE. IN ROMAN ART
TEACHER PROGRAMS HAVE DECLINED
BY TWO THIRDS OVER THE LAST
ROUGHLY TWO DECADES AT THE SAME
TIME THE DEMAND YOUR HIRES HAS
OUTPACED THE NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES COMPLETING THESE
PROGRAMS SINCE THE PANDEMIC
DISTRICT HAVE FACED NEW
CHALLENGES INCREASED NUMBER OF
TEACHER RETIREMENTS AND
RESIGNATIONS SOMETIMES MID YEAR
AS YOU NOTED. THIS PUTS DISTRICT
IN A TOP POSITION TO RELY ON
UNDER TEACHERS WHO HAVEN'T
COMPLETED THEIR CREDENTIALS HAVE
EMERGENCY CREDENTIALS ARE WORSE
SUBSTITUTES ARE WORSE NO
TEACHERS I WE NEED MORE
QUALIFIED TEACHERS AND RIGHT NOW
YOU KNOW HOW THE RULES ARE YOU
GET A DEGREE IN FOUR YEARS YOU
CAN GET A JOB LIKE YOUR FRIENDS
COLLEAGUES DO YOU CAN DECIDE YOU
WILL BECOME A TEACHER BUT A
SCHOOL FRIEND NOTHER YEAR GET
MORE DEBT FOR GO A YEAR OF
INCOME TO GET A JOB IN TEACHING
THAT SOMETIMES PAYS LESS THAN
YOUR FRIENDS ARE GETTING WITH A
FOUR YEAR DEGREE. SO ONE WAY WE
CAN ADDRESS THIS IS HAVING MORE
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREP PROGRAM
SO YOU DO A BOTH WHILE YOU'RE
GETTING YOUR UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE AT THIS BILL OF COURSE
WILL HAVE A FOCUS ON SURE RICH
FIELD SUCH A SPECIAL. AD
BILINGUAL. STEM IN E. C. E. THIS
CAN BE A WIN WIN FOR CALIFORNIA.
OUR SCHOOLS AND CERTAINLY OUR
TEACHERS I WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
WITNESSES RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT. OF ONE WITH. BY. YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME'S
ERIK BAHNSON I AM THE
SUPERINTENDENT WITH THE
PLACERVILLE SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND
I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION- AS YOU KNOW SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SOCIAIS ASIAN-
REPRESENTS OVER TWO THIRDS OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF STUDENT OF EIGHTY A
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OR BELOW-
WE'RE WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT-
AB TWENTY FOUR OH ONE AND THANK
ASSEMBLY- MCCARTY FOR
AUTHORIZING THIS IMPORTANT BILL-
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL WHERE THE
SEVERE TEACHER SHORTAGE- AND IT
IS GETTING WORSE- THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE. ALSO HAVE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND HIT SMALLER
DISTRICTS WILL DISTRICTS HARD-
FOR EXAMPLE I'LL JUST GIVE A
PERSONAL EXAMPLE OF THIS- I HAVE
I HAVE SIXTY SIX TEACHERS WITHIN
MY DISTRICT. I HAVE TWELVE
THEY'RE LEAVING AT THE END OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR. OF CLOSE 220%
OF MY TEACHING FORCES LEAVING
THAT I'M GONNA NEED REPLACE-
CALLOUS EFFORTS ARE BEING MADE
TO REPLACE THESE THESE TEACHERS
THEY ARE DONE THROUGH LOOKING
WITHIN THE STATE OUT OF STATE
AND EVEN OUT OF THE COUNTRY- AND
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO REPLACE THE
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE- THIS
ADDRESS SO BEING NOT BEING
REPLACED IS NOT A DIRECT DIRECT
RESULT OF. THE EFFORT THAT IS
BEING DONE. IT'S CONCERNING
BECAUSE WE ON'T KNOW THE FULL
TIME P. CREDENTIALS ARE THE BEST
WAY FOR OUR STUDENTS TO LEARN.
AND HAVING SUBSTITUTES OR EVEN
NON CREDENTIALED TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM IS NOT THE WAY TO GO.
S. STA APPRECIATE THE AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION THIS COMMITTEE HAS
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE AS WELL AS
ADDRESSING OTHER SHORTAGES- FOR
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH. GROWING
THE INTEGRATED TEACHER PROGRAM
IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL TO HELPING BUILD AND
SUSTAIN OUR TEACHERS WORKFORCE
AS A TRACK PEOPLE INTO THE
WORKFORCE WILL LIKELY WOULDN'T
PURSUE THIS FILLED OTHERWISE.
THESE PROGRAMS ALSO PRODUCE
FULLY QUALIFIED TEACHER AT A
FASTER PACE. I RECEIVED MY
TEACHER CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
THROUGH PROGRAM JUST LIKE THIS.
AS POINTED OUT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS HAS SUCCESSFULLY
PRODUCED A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL TEACHERS. S. IS THE A
PRE SHAVE THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE'S COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING THAT THE PROGRAM
FOCUSES ON PRODUCING TEACHER
SHORTAGE AREAS. THANKS AGAIN AND
RE RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU YOU
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT. UP IT USED TO SORRY YOUR BACKS
IS LIKE A FIELD TRIP WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IT- MISTER CHAIRMAN JEFF
FROST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN DISTRICTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION YET BECAUSE OUR
COMMITTEE HAS NOT MET. BUT THIS
IS AN ISSUE- THAT WE HAVE LONG
SUPPORTED THE CONCEPT OF
CREATING TEACHER COLLEGES IS
DONE EVERYWHERE EXCEPT IN
CALIFORNIA- IN THIS APPROACH IS
GOING TO GET TO EXACTLY WHAT
YOUR FIRST WITNESS TALKED ABOUT.
THE GREAT BUILT AND- WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEE
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT I JUST
WANNA COMMENT COULD BE ALMOST
MCCARTY- I SEE YOU HAVE THE CTC
ADMINISTERING THIS I HOPE THEY
GET BACK IN THEIR OFFICES SOON
AND OPEN THEM SO THEY- CAN
ADMINISTER THIS. AS I CALLED
OVER THE OTHER DAY AND REALIZE
THAT. NO ONE ANSWERS THE PHONE
THEY DON'T PHONE NUMBER BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE- BUT I THINK
THE COMING BACK SHORTLY. SO
HOPEFULLY- I CAN GIVE THEY WILL
MISS AND A GOOD CELL PHONE
NUMBER IF YOU WANT A ARE
EXACTLY- BUT I MEAN. SO I HAVE
AN ISSUE AS A TEACHER. YES HOW
MANY DREADED THOUSAND OTHER
TEACHERS AND STATE THAT.
PROBABLY NEED SERVICE FROM THE
CDC TO PROVIDE A CLOSED. SO BUT
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE- BUT EITHER
WAY I. LISTEN I WE MADE A
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE A FEW YEARS
AGO WITH MY BILL RIGHT THAT
ALLOWED. FOR TEACHERS TO
COMBINE. THE CREDENTIAL
EXPERIENCE IN THAT FOR YEARS.
AND NOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS BUILD UPON THAT. I WOULD
JUST SAY SOMETHING I STATED
EARLIER IS. AS WE GET THIS MONEY
OUT. WE NEED TO SEE RESULTS
RIGHT IT CAN'T JUST BE THAT THEY
COLLABORATED THEY PLANNED. IT'S
GONNA BE WHAT ARE THEY PRODUCE
RIGHT. BECAUSE THIS TO ME IS A
NO BRAINER AS FAR AS AN AVERAGE.
OF THE OTHER NO BRAINERS
LOWERING CLASS SIZES. BECAUSE
YOUR NEW TEACHER CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST CLASS SIZES. IT'S
KILLER OUT THERE WHEN YOUR NEW
TEACHER TO HAVE THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX KIDS IN A CLASSROOM
ABOUT. AYE WHAT WHAT AT THIRTY
SIX. AS A NEW MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER. RIGHT THEY CAN EAT YOU
ALIVE REAL QUICK IF YOU'RE NOT
PREPARED. YOU KNOW YOU ARE
PREPARED THEY'RE GONNA TRY IT'S
THEIR JOB THEIR EIGHTH GRADERS
RIGHT- SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL'S MCCARTY ANY.
OTHER COMMENTS- MISTER LEE.
THANK YOU BRING BILL FORD-
MISTER CARTY- YOU KNOW AND
BUDGET UP TO TALK WELL I TALK
ABOUT SHARING MY CONCERNS WITH.
AS WELL AS A NEW TEACHERS FOR
GOING. ALL YEAR OF INCOME AND
BASICALLY PAYING TO WORK AS
WELL. SO I THINK THIS IS REALLY
VALUABLE AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE
OUT AS CO AUTHOR IF THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY SO. RIGHT DO WE HAVE
A MOTION MR LEE MOTIONS MISTER
BENNETT SECONDS ARE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR OH ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI THE
DONAL I'D DALY. ALII SENATE
SENATE SENATE I CAN N. I. LI LI
I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTED IS ALISTAIR MCCARTY THANK
YOU WITH THAT WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR FINE REFORMISTS
RIVAS. IT'S AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT- WOULD HELP BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS WHO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ENGLISH LEARNER GROWTH
AND ACHIEVEMENT DATA TO BE
PROPERLY COLLECTED AND UPLOADED
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S WEBSITE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO VIEW. ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE FIVE MILLION ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED IN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THESE
STUDENTS ARE LONG TERM ENGLISH
LEARNERS. ANOTHER A HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS ARE AT RISK OF BECOMING
LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS.
CURRENTLY ALL TYPES OF ENGLISH
LEARNER STUDENTS ARE CLASSIFIED
INTO A SINGLE CATEGORY OF THEIR
LEARNING STATUS WITHOUT REGARD
TO THEIR SEPARATE LEVELS OF
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. THIS MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND THEIR RESPECTIVE
ACHIEVEMENTS PROGRESS AND THEIR
NEEDS WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
PROPERLY DIFFERENTIATE THE
UNIQUE ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENT
GROUPS. CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO BETTER SERVE OUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS BY REQUIRING CD
TO FURTHER SEPARATE ACHIEVEMENT
AND ROMAN AND OTHER OUTCOMES FOR
LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS AT RISK OF BECOMING
LONG TERM. ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY OF MANUEL WHEN
DRAW STRONG ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY FOR CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER. AND DOCTOR MUCH
MARLENE BATTISTA DIRECTOR OF
CERTIFICATED. HUMAN RESOURCES
FOR THE OXNARD SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES. I
THINK PRESS THE BOOK THERE
SHOULD BE A BUTTON DOWN THERE M.
I. C. GREAT WELL GOOD EVENING
EVERYBODY- I'M- HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT. PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WE HOPE WILL SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY FOR LONG
TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS AND OUR
STUDENTS AT RISK OF BECOMING
LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS. OVER
THE PAST DECADE CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER ON THE ISSUE OF
ALLTEL'S. CORNING THE TERM AND
DEVELOPING THE ROBUST DEFINITION
THAT WE HAVE TODAY. AS YOU MAY
KNOW LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS
OR ELL TELLS OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS WHO HAVE BEEN ENROLLED
IN U. S. SCHOOLS. FOR SIX OR
MORE YEARS AND WHO HAVE REMAINED
AT THE SAME LEVEL OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY OR
REGRESSED FOR TWO CONSECUTIVE
YEARS. SO THESE ARE STUDENTS ARE
STUCK IN THE SYSTEM. BY
DEFINITION ALL LONG TERM ENGLISH
LEARNERS OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
SECONDARY SCHOOLS THAT MEANS
THAT THESE ARE STUDENTS IN
GRADES SIX TO TWELVE. AND WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE DATA- BRIGHT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC FOR THAT
NINETEEN TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR. WE
KNOW THAT NEARLY HALF OF ALL
ENGLISH LEARNERS IN GRADES SIX
TO TWELVE. OUR LONG TERM ENGLISH
LEARNERS. THESE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IN OUR
SYSTEM. MOREOVER WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE DULY IDENTIFIED A
STUDENTS TO DISABILITIES WE SEE
THAT 36% OF THE STUDENTS ARE
DULY IDENTIFIED. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX TO MAKE
THE STUDENTS MORE VISIBLE BY
ENSURING THAT ACHIEVEMENT AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION DATA IS
FURTHER DISAGGREGATED BY L.
TELLS. AND STUDENTS AT RISK OF
BECOMING OUTHOUSE FOR THAT ARE
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
BETTER SUPPORT TEACHERS AND
STAFF. TO SERVE THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF THE STUDENTS. MOREOVER THIS
WOULD NOT CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL
REPORTING BURDEN FOR DISTRICTS
THE DATA REQUESTED IN THIS
LEGISLATION. IS ALREADY REPORTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- THROUGH THE DISTRICTS
VOTER REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL
REPORTING BY DISTRICTS. GO AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S DR MARLENE BATTISTA
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF%
CERTIFICATED HUMAN RESOURCES FOR
OXNARD SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT I'M
HERE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATORS ONE OF THEIR BOARD
MEMBERS. WE BELIEVE THERE'S A
NEED TO BE PROACTIVE IN OUR
CONTINUING APPROACH TO ENSURE
OUR LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE PROVIDED WITH THE NECESSARY
SUPPORT AND PROGRAMS THEY NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. WE KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED LEARNING
LOTS FOR ALL STUDENTS BUT MOST
ESPECIALLY OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND HAS PUT MANY MORE STUDENTS
AT RISK OF BECOMING LONG TERM
ENGLISH LEARNERS. OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM FOR DISAGGREGATED DATA
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
ENGLISH LEARNERS DOES NOT
PROVIDE ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO
MONITOR THEIR ACHIEVEMENT
LEAVING US WITHOUT VALUABLE DATA
ENABLING US TO MAKE CHANGES TO
OUR SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENTS. ABEIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WILL PROVIDE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK INTO THE
CONSTRUCT USED TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS BY ALLOWING US TO BREAK
DOWN SPECIAL EDUCATION DATA BY
ENGLISH LANGUAGE STATUS TYPE OF
DISABILITY AND SPECIFIC LEARNING
DISABILITY CATEGORY.
ADDITIONALLY A. B. ONE EIGHT SIX
EIGHT WILL ENABLE US TO STUDY
THE ACHIEVEMENT AND ROMAN AS
WELL AS OUR OUTLOOK OTHER
OUTCOMES OF OUR EXISTING LONG
TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS STUDENTS
AS WELL AS THOSE THAT ARE AT
REST FOR BECOMING A LONG TERM
ENGLISH LEARNERS. HOW MAY
BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL IS A FUNDAMENTAL STEP THAT
WILL ALLOW OUR STATE TO EVALUATE
WHETHER WERE ADEQUATELY SERVING
THE STUDENTS BY CREATING
SUCCESSFUL POLICIES AND
STRATEGIES TO HELP OUR LONG TERM
ENGLISH LEARNERS TO TRULY
SUCCEED. ON BEHALF OF COPY I
URGE YOU AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRIAN RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT. JUST LIKE A PSYCHO ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER BAKER HELP BEING THE L.
A. COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COMMUNICATE
THEIR SUPPORT. GENEVIEVE COUNTY
SHOW FOR ON BEHALF OF GENERATION
UP IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
ANY- ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
COME FORWARD. SENIOR OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS READY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE A
MOTION. MISTER BENNETT MOVES
THIS REALLY SECONDS IS REMOVED
AND SECOND YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THIS CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FOR AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL ARE THE DONALD I DALY
. SALII BENNETT HI THE BILL
BENNETT I CHEN. CAN I LEAVE LEVY
I'VE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THE SIX FOOT SO IT
IS I WILL MOVE YOUR NEXT ON THIS
RIVAS WHICH IS AB I'D FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE YOU
A PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WANT TO START BY ONCE AGAIN
THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
BILL AND I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE WOULD FOSTER YOUTHS PASSION
FOR LEARNING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WAYS TO MITIGATE ITS
EFFECTS THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
CLIMATE CHANGE OF COURSE
REQUIREMENT FOR GRADES ONE
THROUGH TWELVE SO THAT OUR
FUTURE LEADERS CAN GAIN THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO CREATE. A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. A REPORT BY STANFORD
UNIVERSITY EXAMINED HOW
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY HAD
BENEFITED STUDENTS. FROM NURSERY
SCHOOL TO SECONDARY SCHOOL. THE
STUDY FOUND. THAT 83% OF
STUDENTS IMPROVE THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL BEHAVIOR. STUDENTS
WHO ARE BEING EDUCATED ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
CLEARLY BETTER PREPARED TO FIGHT
FOR A BETTER FUTURE. BUT NOT ALL
CHILDREN ARE BEING PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN. I ALSO
KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO
LEARN ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE IN
SCHOOL THEY'RE DEMANDING THIS
AND THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER THIS COURSE IN THE REGULAR
SCHOOL DAY. CALIFORNIA HAS
CERTAINLY MADE SOME PROGRESS ON
ADVANCING CLIMATE CHANGE
LITERACY BUT THERE REMAINS MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE TO TEACH THESE
TOPICS AND OUR SCHOOLS SINCE THE
STATE'S ATTEMPTS TO TEACH ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE REMAIN OPTIONAL.
RECOGNIZING THAT EDUCATION IS
THE FIRST STEP IN COMBATING
CLIMATE CHANGE IT ONLY TOOK THE
INITIATIVE MANDATING CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION IN EVERY SCHOOL
GRADE. MEXICO QUICKLY FOLLOWED
AND AMENDED THEIR CONSTITUTION
TO INCLUDE CLIMATE CHANGE AS A
REQUIREMENT OF EDUCATION.
MEANWHILE IN THE US NEW JERSEY
IS THE FIRST STATE TO REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO TEACH CLIMATE CHANGE
. CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY FALLING
BEHIND OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES THAT TEACH ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AS A RESULT WERE
MISSING CRITICAL OPPORTUNITIES
TO TEACH THOSE WHO WILL BE BEST
POSITIONED TO HELP DELIVER THE
SOLUTIONS TO MITIGATE AND ADAPT
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE WILL EMPOWER
STUDENTS TO FIND CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTIONS BY MAKING CLIMATE
CHANGE A STATE EDUCATION
PRIORITY. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY REBEKAH
FRANK CO FOUNDER OF SIERRA CLUB
CLIMATE LITERACY COMMITTEE UP
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
CHAPTER. THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. I WILL PROBABLY
ALL HEARD ABOUT GRETA AS IN
GREATER BURKE THE SWEDISH
CLIMATE ACTIVIST. BUT HOW ABOUT
RISHI OR ELLA- SHERA FOR AARON.
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE STUDENTS
THE CLIMATE LITERACY TEAM WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO WORK WITHIN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PASS
RESOLUTIONS SUPPORTING A CLIMATE
CURRICULA. IN FACT I'M NOT SURE
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT THE ENERGY OF THESE
ACTIVISTS. ON THE ONE HAND THEY
HAVE RECOGNIZE THE DARKNESS OF
OUR SITUATION. ACCORDING TO THE
U. N. EVEN IF NATIONAL
COMMITMENTS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
BY TWENTY THIRTY OR KEPT THE
TEMPERATURE WILL CONTINUE TO
INCREASE TO TWO POINT SEVEN
DEGREES CENTIGRADE. BY THE END
OF THE CENTURY EXITING THE
CRUCIAL MAXIMUM OF ONE POINT
FIVE DEGREES. THESE ACTIVISTS
KNOW THAT GREENHOUSE GASES NEED
TO BE REDUCED BY HALF BY TWENTY
THIRTY TO AVOID THIS OUTCOME. ON
THE OTHER HAND THEY ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THEIR
FELLOW STUDENTS DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND CLIMATE CHANGE. OR
FEEL POWERLESS TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT. AND THROUGH EXPERIENCE
THEY SAY THE GAPS AND HOW
CLIMATE CHANGE IS COVERED IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS IT'S NOT
ABSENT BUT ITS BODY. THESE GAPS
CAN BE NARROWED THROUGH THIS
BILL ESTABLISHING REQUIREMENTS
FOR ALL OF THE STATE'S ONE
THOUSAND PLUS DISTRICTS. AS PART
OF SCIENCE INSTRUCTION STUDENTS
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT WHAT'S CAUSING THE
CLIMATE TO CHANGE ITS EFFECTS ON
THEIR LIVES AND COMMUNITIES. THE
ACTIONS WHICH CAN BE TAKEN TO
COUNTERACT THE EFFECTS AND THE
WAY USED TO ADOPT THE INEVITABLE
CHANGES. EDUCATION IS VITAL TO
OVERCOME LACK OF KNOWLEDGE AND
MISCONCEPTION AND TO LAY A
FOUNDATION FOR ACTION. IF WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE HAD TO MAKE
HARD CHOICES UP TO NOW ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE WE CAN BE CERTAIN
THEY WILL BECOME INCREASINGLY
HARDER. YET THEY MAY NOT HAPPEN
OR AT LEAST NOT HAPPEN QUICKLY
ENOUGH WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF
TODAY'S STUDENTS. CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE TAXPAYERS VOTERS AND
LEGISLATORS. THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
AVOID EVER WORSENING EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR THIS AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS US TO WORK
TOGETHER. RELYING ON EDUCATED
PUBLIC SUPPORTIVE OF TAKING WELL
INFORMED ACTION. AT BOTH THE
POLICY AND THE PERSONAL LEVELS.
THIS BILL GETS IS MOVING IN THE
NEED A DIRECTION PLEASE PLEASE
ARTIST. THE JOB THANK YOU I
CANNOT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROSS BARKLEY ABOUT THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN STEVE BAKER WITH
THEIR AND REDUCES HIS FOR TEN
STRANDS IN SUPPORT. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO RODRIGUEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. GENEVIEVE COUNTY
SHOW FOR ON BEHALF OF GENERATION
UP A YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IMPORTER. MARK ABSTAINED
CALIFORNIAN FIRE MENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL WITH THE
TEACHING OF CLIMATE CHANGE
OUTSIDE OF THE CONTEXT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE- SCIENCE OR EARTH
SYSTEMS COURSE LEADS TO- EAT E.
E. D. E. A WAX PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH A CUT
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ISSUE I HAVE SEEN IT
CLASSROOMS CLIMATE CHANGE BEING
TAUGHT IN ISOLATION AND IT
DOESN'T REALLY COVER THE NEED
AND THE DETAIL AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TINO FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
EVERY MOVES AT ITS SECOND BY
STALLING. OF THREE ON A SECOND
THIS. MOREOVER YEAH MISTER
BENNETT OKAY SO WITH THAT MR-
THE VICE CHAIR IS A QUESTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DINO I HAVE A
QUESTION SO. BEFORE I HAVE IN
THE ASSEMBLY I SERVE ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD SO I'M JUST WITH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE SCIENCE
FRAMEWORK IS OP AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TO FOR TEXTBOOKS AND
CURRICULUM TO BE. YOU KNOW
READOPTED AND TO MAKE THE
IMPORTANT I. BELIEVE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IS IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS
TO BE LEARNING AND I DO HAVE
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL AND THEY ARE
LEARNING. ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND MADE IT MAY BE SPOTTY I'M-
NOT AN EXPERT ON THAT. BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU HAD
CONSIDERED WAITING FOR THAT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO THAT THERE
WOULD BE TIME. FOR SCHOOL BOARDS
AND TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
MINISTRATIONS TO WEIGH IN ON TO
MAKE SURE THAT CURRICULUM. WAS
READY TO BE ADOPTED. YEAH RIGHT
NOW- THIS BECOMES IN EFFECT THE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL
YEAR. ARE THERE ALREADY IS
CURRICULUM OUT THERE- THAT
TEACHES ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
LIKE YOU SAID SOME SCHOOLS ARE
DOING IT- WHICH IS GREAT AND YOU
KNOW A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE MADE THIS A PRIORITY- BUT
RIGHT NOW IT IS STILL OPTIONAL.
RIGHT AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE INCLUDING IT AS
PART OF THE INSTRUCTION. OF LIKE
BECAUSE THE CUT THE CURRICULUM
IT IS THERE AND READY FOR
TEACHERS TO USE. OF THAT'S WHY
WE'RE WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT. YOU KNOW MAKE THIS
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL
YEAR. GREAT THANK YOU IT IS IN
THE FRAMEWORK. NAY THAT THAT
JUST JUST KNOW THAT AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS- WE DID HAVE A
CONVERSATION I WAS WHEN I MAKING
THIS OR- A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT YES OUR STUDENTS DO
NOT NEED ONE MORE. GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. HEY THIS BUILDING
SEEMS TO HIT GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS ON LIKE THERE. YOU
KNOW. WHATEVER YOU WANT- THAT IS
A PRETTY IMPORTANT TOPIC I
TAUGHT IT AND COME TO MY OFFICE
INITIALLY WHEN I TAUGHT- BUT
AGAIN IF PEOPLE ARE GONNA COME
FORWARD WITH ONE MORE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT I WANT TO IT TO
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE OFF BECAUSE-
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ACTUALLY BECAUSE I HAD THAT I
THOUGHT ACTUALLY WAS ELECTIVES
GEOGRAPHY. RIGHT MANY G. BUT
EITHER WAY IT WAS ELECTED- SO
THAT THAT THAT YOU KNOW WE DO A
LITTLE BIT OF PUSH BACK ON THAT
JUST BECAUSE AGAIN. EVERYBODY
WANTS A NEW GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT NO ONE WANTS TO
REMOVE ONE. AND THAT'S A REALLY
CHALLENGING. FOR OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT THEY'VE ALREADY
GOT SO MANY. THINGS THEY HAVE TO
DO. AND ARE ALREADY UNDER FUNDED
BUT YOU DON'T HEAR THAT SPEECH
AGAIN. ALL RIGHT AWAY THAT- YOU
CALLS. I HAVEN'T BUT- I KNOW I
DID ACCEPT YOUR AMENDMENTS
MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT THANK YOU. UP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DONALD HI
DONALD I'D DALY. SALLY NOT
VOTING SENATE SENATE I CAN. CAN
I LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE QUIRK-SILVA. THE HOUSE FIVE
OH TWO IS OUT WILL MOVE HERE NOW
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX- AGAIN-
THREE OF US IS AB TWO THREE
SEVEN TWO THREE SEVEN FIVE. WELL
THAT'S ON CONSENSO YOU'RE FREE
IT'S ON CONSENT RIGHT OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU YEAH.
I MET HER IN THE FRONT OR GOING
TO FILE NUMBER SIXTEEN THAT'S AB
TWO SIX FOUR ZERO. I AM SIXTEEN
UNIVERSITY ONE READY IF YOU HAVE
WITNESSES THEY MAY COME FORWARD
AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR WORKING WITH
ME TO IMPROVE THIS BILL. I'LL
START BY SAYING THAT WE'VE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. AB TWO SIX
FOUR ZERO THE ZAKI BILL AS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT PARENTS CAREGIVERS
EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS ALL HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION. AND STRATEGIES TO
REDUCEALLERGIC REACTIONS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND EARLY
EDUCATION CENTERS. OVER FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION CHILDRENIN
AMERICA HAVE FOOD ALLERGIES
NEARLY 40% OF THESE CHILDREN
HAVE EXPERIENCED A SEVERE
ALLERGIC REACTION. AND MANY OF
THESE REACTIONS HAPPENED ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. IT IS CRUCIAL
TO EMPHASIZE THAT FOOD ALLERGIES
CAN BE LIFE THREATENING
ANAPHYLAXIS IS A POTENTIALLY
LETHAL ALLERGIC REACTION THAT
CAN HAPPEN WITHIN MINUTES AND IF
NOT PROPERLY TREATED. CAN BE
FATAL. NO STUDENT SHOULD FEEL
UNSAFE ON CAMPUS AND NO PARENT
SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEIR CHILD SCHOOL IS
AWARE OF ALL AVAILABLE RESOURCES
AND BEST PRACTICES WHEN IT COMES
TO FOOD ALLERGIES. THAT'S WHY I
INTRODUCED THIS MEASURE AB TWO
SIX FOUR ZERO WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CREATE AN
ACCESSIBLE AND DIGITAL RESOURCE
THAT WILL INCLUDE PRACTICAL
INFORMATION PLANNING STEPS AND
STRATEGIES FOR REDUCING ALLERGIC
REACTIONS ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND
EARLY EDUCATION CENTERS. IT WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
PARENTS ARE AWARE OF THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LAWS HOW TO INITIATE
INDIVIDUALIZED FOOD ALLERGY
MANAGEMENT AND PREVENTION PLANS
HOW TO OBTAIN INGREDIENT LIST
FROM SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND MUCH MORE. TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS AKKI AND PRISCILLA
HERNANDEZ. THANK YOU TO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS. THANK HELLO BOARD
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JACKIE
MINIONS AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
ZAKI BILL AB TWENTY SIX FOR YOU
WILL PROVIDE ONLINE RESOURCE
GUIDE FOR FOOD ALLERGIES FOR
KIDS AND ADULTS. IT WILL SHOW
WHAT RESOURCES ARE VAILABLE
WHAT TO DO IF YOU HAVE FOOD
ALLERGIES AND HOW TO PREVENT
ANAPHYLAXIS. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T RELY ON
INFORMATION. INGREDIENTS LIST.
IN OUR DOUBTS JUST KNOWING WHAT
TO DO FOR A- I. FEEL SAFE
INCLUDED AT SCHOOL. I WOULD I
WOULD EITHER NOT FINDING GETTING
EVERYBODY EVEN WORSE TRUST ME I
KNOW. BUT THIS GUY WILL SHOW
THAT OUR SCHOOL CARES AND JUST
WANTS TO MAKE US FEEL INCLUDED.
BUT THIS GUY WILL HELP US A LOT
MORE. INITIAL ESPECIALLY HELP
OUR DEL. THESE FEELINGS ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE SOMETIMES YOU
CAN'T YOU CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
SNACKS ALL THE ACTIVITIES I JUST
HANG OUT WITH THE FRIENDS
BECAUSE THEIR P. B. AND J. AND
WHEN YOU DO HAVE A REACTION IT
CAN BE SCARY. IT CAN ALSO BE.
DIFFERENT AND MAKE YOU FEEL A
LITTLE EMBARRASSED AND DON'T GET
ME WRONG BEING DIFFERENT ISN'T
BAD AT ALL. ACTUALLY IN FACT IN
BEING IN THE CAN BE A GREAT
THING. BUT SOMETIMES YOU JUST
WANT TO BE. WITH YOUR FRIENDS
STAY BEING AFRAID OF FOOD.
CALIFORNIA'S A WONDERFUL STATE
AND I THINK IT COULD AND WILL BE
BETTER WITH AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
. THANK YOU FOR BEING OUR VOICES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN MAKING
SURE THE KIDS WITH FOOD
ALLERGIES IN SCHOOL HAD THE MOST
PROPER AND DEDICATED INFORMATION
POSSIBLE. LUCIEN I ASK YOU TO
PASS AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
ADVOCATE COMMITTEE TODAY FOR ALL
THE KIDS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
ONE TIME WELL DONE WELL DONE. I
DO NEXT WITNESSES OKAY THAT THAT
IS YOUR WITNESS AGAIN WELL DONE
THAT THAT IS THE WITNESS OKAY
GREAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. SEEING NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. I WILL GO TO THE BACK
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR
LEE. YES I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORTY CAN BE
DEFINITELY VERY SCARY WHEN YOU
WANT TO JUST ENJOY FOOD WITH
YOUR FRIENDS AND- ZACH I JUST
WANNA ALSO COMPARE- TO COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR REALLY EXCELLENT
LOBBYING YOU CAUGHT ME IN THE
HALLWAY. WHAT IS REALLY BUSY
USING COMMITTEES YOU'RE REALLY
INCESSANT SO I THINK OF A BRIGHT
FUTURE OF PUBLIC POLICY SO GOOD
JOB AND- HOPEFULLY MOVE THE
BILL. RIGHT. RIGHT BY THE TIME
YOU'RE READY TO RUN FOR ASSEMBLY
MISTER LEGAL STRONG PROBABLY
STILL BE HERE. A MISTER CHEN.
THANK YOU MR I HAS A MAJOR
RESERVATIONS REGARDING THE BILL
AS THE AUTHOR- IS ALWAYS BALLING
ME DISPARAGINGLY BUT- EXACTLY
WITH YOUR EXCELLENT TESTIMONY
ONCE AND I WAS SO IMPRESSED BY
FAR THE BEST TESTIMONY I'VE HAD
ALL YEAR- I AM SCARED THAT YOU
MIGHT ONE OF MY DISTRICT AND RUN
AGAINST ME SO BASED ON YOUR AGE
AT ALL TO WORRY ABOUT THAT BUT-
INCREDIBLE TESTIMONY VERY PROUD
OF YOU. AND AS MR- SOMEONE
AROUND POLICE SAID YOU HAVE A
BRIGHT FUTURE IN POLITICS IF YOU
SO CHOSE. AMAZING TEST MARKET
JOB. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM INTO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. DID WE HAVE A
MOTION YEAH WE DID WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND. WE DID YOU
MAY CLOSE. AS YOU CAN SEE A
PROBABLY WASN'T REALLY NEEDED
HERE TODAY YOU COULD HANDLE THIS
ALL. BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL AND AS A MOTHER WITH A
DAUGHTER WHO IS ABOUT TO START
KINDERGARTEN. I BELIEVE IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT WE PROVIDE PARENTS
TEACHERS ANYONE DEALING WITH
THEIR CHILDREN THE INFORMATION
ON HOW TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN
SAFE. FROM ALLERGIC REACTIONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI THE
DONALD I DAILY. DAILY AYE
BENNETT BENNETT I CAN. CHEN I
BELIEVE LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY I
QUIRK-SILVA. WELL SIX ALSO IT IS
OUT WALDRON THANK YOU. I WILL
NOT MAKE SO MUCH. NUMBER ONE THE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN MISS RUBIO IS
NOT HERE OTHER SHOWS OFFICER IF
I APOLOGIZE THIS RUBIO AB TWO I
AM THIRTEEN AB TWO FIVE SIX FIVE
. YOUR WITNESSES MAY COME
FORWARD YOU HAVE ANY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY FIVE HERE TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS MEASURE AND
ACCEPTING ALL OF THAT
RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
LISTED ON THE ANALYSIS. MEMBERS
AS WE ARE ALSO KEENLY AWARE
SCIENCE AND MATH ARE KEYS TO
ADDRESSING GLOBAL CHALLENGES AND
FINDING SOLUTIONS FOR ISSUES
LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
CALIFORNIA HAS WILL- WORLD CLASS
STANDARDS FOR SCIENCE AND MATH
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
ADOPTED THE NEXT GENERATION
SCIENCE STANDARDS AND CURRENTLY
OUR STATE IS LOOKING AT A
REVISED AND IMPROVED MATHEMATICS
FRAMEWORK. NOW WE MUST INVEST IN
SUPPORTING TEACHERS IMPLEMENTING
. THESE STANDARDS AND FRAMEWORK
WE KNOW THAT TOO MANY STUDENTS
ARE NOT GETTING THE ACADEMIC
INSTRUCTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THEY
NEED AND DESERVE. THIS LEADS TO
INEQUITIES IN LEARNING OUTCOMES
AND HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
COLLEGE GOING RATES AND PROVIDE
A PROFESSIONAL PERTINENTES FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE GLOVE COVERED
NINETEEN HAVE OUR HAS REVEALED
THESE INEQUITIES LIKE NEVER
BEFORE AND NOW IS THE TIME TO
INVEST IN OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
TEACHERS. WE WANT AND NEED MORE
STUDENTS TO BE PREPARED FOR HIGH
PAYING AN IMPACTFUL STEM CAREERS
AND WE WANT OUR TEACHERS TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUED
LEARNING AND PROFESSIONAL
COLLABORATION TO SUPPORT GREAT
GREAT TEACHING PRACTICES. THIS
IS WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE WHICH
WILL IMPROVE MATH AND SCIENCE
INSTRUCTION BY INVESTING IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
SCIENCE AND MATH TEACHERS AND
TEACHER LEADERS THE APPROACH OF
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE IS TO
BUILD ON WHAT WE KNOW WORKS
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE FOR
LOCAL EDUCATORS TO COME TOGETHER
AND FOR NETWORKS- FOR TEACHERS
AND TEACHER LEADERS TO SHARE AND
BUILD ON THEIR EXPERIENCES. I
HAVE ALSO SUBMITTED A BUDGET
REQUEST TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT POSSIBLE BY IMPROVING
HOW WE TRAIN TEACHERS TO TEACH
SCIENCE AND MATH WE CAN MAKE
THESE COURSES MORE ACCESS TO
OUR- STUDENT POPULATION. IT WILL
ALSO HELP EDUCATORS LEARN HOW TO
TEACH SCIENCE AND MATH IN WAYS
THAT ENGAGE STUDENTS. AND I AM
SO PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
COALITION IS WORKING TOGETHER TO
ADVOCATE FOR A NEW BLUEPRINT FOR
ACTION. FOR EQUITABLE SCIENCE
AND MATH EDUCATION. THIS
BLUEPRINT IS A GREAT PLAN THAT
WILL SERVE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WELL AND I APPLAUD YOUR ADVOCACY
FOR THE CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS-
YOU ARE YOU ARE RECOMMENDING FOR
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS. TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME BRIAN RIVAS SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
EDUCATIONAL. EDUCATION TRUST
WEST AND PETE AARON PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCIENCE EDUCATORS TO SPEAK TO
THE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRIAN RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST THANK YOU
TO YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS AND DEVELOPING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. UP WE CO
SPONSORED THIS BECAUSE WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT ACHIEVEMENT
LEVELS IN MATH AND SCIENCE AND
MAYBE MRE THAN THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR ACCESS TO COLLEGE. IN FOR
OPPORTUNITIES LATER IN LIFE. IF
I MAY. JUST WANT TO SHARE A
COUPLE QUICK DATA POINTS FROM
THE LATEST ACHIEVEMENT.
ASSESSMENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND GRANTED. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS URGING CAUTION
BECAUSE WE WERE IN A PANDEMIC
AND FEWER STUDENTS TOOK THE
TESTS. BUT NONETHELESS 34% OF
STUDENTS IN MATH MATTER EXCEEDED
STANDARDS AND ONLY ONE IN FIVE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS. AND ONE IN
FIVE LET NEXT STUDENTS MET OR
EXCEEDED STANDARDS. IN SCIENCE
IT WAS 29% IN ONLY ONE IN SIX OF
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND ONE OF
ONE IN SIX OF LATIN X. STUDENTS.
WE DO EQUITY AUDITS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL ENTITY OR- AGENCIES
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS TO HELP THEM IMPROVE
POLICY AND PRACTICE FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR. INFREQUENTLY THOSE
ANALYSES YIELD THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO COMPLETING A THROUGH G.
MATH AND SCIENCE IS A STUMBLING
BLOCK IT'S ONE OF THE- THREE OR
FOUR SUBJECTS WITH THE LOWEST
COMPLETION RATES. BEYOND THAT
FOR THOSE WHO MAKE IT TO
COLLEGE. CALCULUS CHEMISTRY AND
PHYSICS TEND TO BE GATEKEEPERS
FOR STUDENTS TO HIGH PAYING
TECHNICAL FIELDS IN THE STEM
STEM FIELDS. AND SO STUDENTS WHO
DON'T DO WELL IN MATH AND
SCIENCE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
INTO COLLEGE AND THEN THEY HAVE
LIMITED OPTIONS WHEN THEY GET
THERE. WE DECIDED TO PARTNER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCIENCE EDUCATORS BECAUSE-
THEY KNOW WHAT WORKS BEST THEY
KNOW WHAT IS NEEDED THEY HAVE
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH THE
LACK OF INVESTMENT IN THE STATE
FRAMEWORK FOR SCIENCE. AND THE
UNEVEN IMPLEMENTATION THAT
RESULTED. THIS BILL PROPOSES AN
INVESTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR MATH AND SCIENCE
EDUCATION AND THEN FUNDING FOR
TEACHER AND SCHOOL SITE LEADERS.
TO IMPROVE INSTRUCTION AND
REALLY TURN AROUND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING WHEN IT COMES TO STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT. WE URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. RIGHT RIGHT YES ALL
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- CASE IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AND CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO WE THANK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO FOR OFFERING IN
CHAMPIONING THIS BILL WE ALSO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING US ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- WE KNOW THAT IF YOU
WANT TO CREATE MEANINGFUL CHANGE
IN CLASSROOMS YOU NEED TO
EMPOWER TEACHERS AS LEADERS
THAT'S WHAT AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FIVE IS DESIGNED TO DO. REAL
PROFESSIONAL RUN TAKES TIME IT
INVOLVES PRACTICE IN THE
CLASSROOM AND IT BUILDS TEACHER
LEADERSHIP THAT LEADS TO LONG
TERM CAPACITY AND EFFICACY. IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE STATE
ALLOCATED ONE A QUARTER BILLION
DOLLARS INTO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO SUPPORT COMMON
CORE I GOT TO ATTEND SOME OF
THOSE TRAININGS IT WAS FIVE DAYS
IN A ROW IN A ROOM WITH A POWER
POINT WITH THE PERSON WHO HAD
JUST BEEN HIRED BY A PUBLISHER-
THERE WAS NO ABILITY TO TRY
THINGS OUT LEARN AND ADJUST
THERE WAS NO LEADERSHIP CAPACITY
BUILT AND IT HONESTLY DIDN'T
LEAD TO MEANINGFUL CLASSROOM
CHANGE. WHEN NDSS WAS ADOPTED ON
THE OTHER HAND THERE WERE NO
STATE FUNDS ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT
IT BUT USING MONEY FROM
FOUNDATIONS GROUPS LIKE CASE
WORKED WITH COUNTY OFFICES
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
PROJECT K. TWELVE ALLIANCE CTA
ADDRESSED WEST CHILDREN NOW AND
OTHERS. WE WERE ABLE TO BUILD
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP AND LEARN
HOW TO GROW TEACHERS INTO
LEADERS AND HOW TO DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
RESPECTED THE REALITIES OF THE
CLASSROOM WE LEARNED HOW TO MAKE
SCIENCE LEARNING EQUITABLE. AND
IMPACTFUL. CDA THE STATE BOARD
AND SUCCESSFULLY CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR MATH
AND SCIENCE EDUCATION TO BRING
ALL THESE GROUPS TOGETHER. AND
WORK WITH DISTRICTS COUNTIES IN
TEACHER LEADERS TO JOIN IN
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE. THIS
COMMUNITY IS A PRACTICE THAT
THIS BILL SUPPORTS BUILDS
EDUCATOR CAPACITIES TO ADVANCE
ACCESS. TO MEANINGFUL MATH AND
SCIENCE TEACHING AND LEARNING.
AND PROMOTES RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING CONNECTING PARTICIPANTS
WITH EXPERTS AND RESEARCHERS AND
SUPPORTING LEADERS. BUT AGAIN
THIS WORK WAS PRIVATELY FUNDED
WE DID GREAT WORK BUT IT WAS
NEVER ENOUGH IN THE STATE IS
BIGGEST CALIFORNIA. I DON'T NEED
TO EXPLAIN TO THIS COMMITTEE WHY
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION SCIENCE
AND MATH IS VITAL TO STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. OR WHY A WORK FORCE
EDUCATED IN SCIENCE AND MATH IS
A KEY TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY. I'M AS
AMENDMENT THIS MEASURE PROVIDES
SUSTAINED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TEACHER LEADERSHIP AND
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING. AND
SUPPORTS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE. FOR
CLASSROOM TEACHERS AND SITE AND
DISTRICT BASED TEAMS CASE
SUPPORTS AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FIVE AND URGES A YES VOTE. THANK
YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT. MY NAME'S
KELLY QUAN MARTIN I AM AN
EDUCATOR AND THE ELK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH
OVER SIXTEEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
I'M A PARENT I AM A BOARD MEMBER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCIENCE EDUCATORS I AM A
TEACHER LEADER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS AND I'M A FACULTY
MEMBER WITH THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AT UC DAVIS AND THE
COLLEGE OF EDUCATION AT SAC
STATE. ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND A
GROUP UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF
FROST REPRESENTING THE
EXPLORATORIUM IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH-
WITH CAPS ME AS WELL. ALSO
WANTED TO THANK MR GARCIA FOR
HIS ANALYSIS AND IS WILLING.
NESS TO- WORK WITH US ON THE
BILL. JESSICA SOCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK
PROJECT OF CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. MARKET MARKUPS IN
CALIFORNIA VIA MENTAL TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION NETWORK AND WEARING
SUPPORT BUT THIS BILL DOES NEED
TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE A
PROVIDE SUPPORT IN DEVELOPING
DIGITAL SKILLS AND THEIR
TEACHERS THAT ARE. BROADLY
ENHANCE BOTH SCIENCE AND
MATHEMATICS INSTRUCTION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREA
BALL HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEEN OF FURTHER
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITIONAL RING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEES ARE
MOTION. OF THE VICE CHAIR MOVES
AND MISTER LEE'S SECONDS- WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THIS
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DEEP PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I'VE
DONE ALL I'D DALLY. DALLY I'LL
BENNETT. THE CHEN THEN I'LL
LEAVE THE AYE MCCARTY RTI
QUIRK-SILVA. YES FIVE OH TOURISM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL NOW
MOVED FIVE ON THE FOURTEEN AGAIN
BY MISS- RUBIO AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FOUR FILE ITEM FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT NOW
ASSEMBLY BELL TWENTY SIX NINETY
FOUR TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE AND BY ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. MEMBERS AS YOU ALL ARE
WELL AWARE CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENTLY FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS WHICH HAS BEEN IT-
EXASPERATED BY A- COURT COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FOUR WILL TACKLE THIS
SHORTAGE BY PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR TEACHER INDUCTION PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY FACING AND I'M
PRESIDENT AND SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS WHICH- WE ALL KNOW IS
CRITICAL TO THE LEARNING OF-
STUDENTS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
FOUR TACKLE THIS RETARDED. BY
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR TEACHER
INDUCTION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
ON NEW TEACHERS WHO ARE REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN A FOUR YEAR DEGREE IN
A SPECIFIC SUBJECT AREA. AND
ROLLING THEY TEACHING
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM AND
PARTICIPATE IN AND IN MANY
INSTANCES PAID FOR BUT IT'S A
PROGRAM. WE THIS REQUIREMENT NOT
ONLY CREATES A DISTINCT A
DISINCENTIVE FOR PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS TO ENTER THE PROFESSION
BUT ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO THE HIGH
NUMBER OF NEW TEACHERS LEAVING
THE PROFESSION. THEREFORE IT IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STATE AND ITS PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING. UP FOR INDUCTION
PROGRAMMES AND PROHIBIT
INDUCTION PROVIDERS FROM
CHARGING YOU TEACH TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FOUR AND IT'S HAPPENING
BUDGET REQUEST WILL ACCOMPLISH
JUST THAT. THE BILL IS SPONSORED
BY SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION. WITH ME
TODAY WE HAVE THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT CHERYL COTTON TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
OF THE CNVENTIONAL COTTON THAT
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT
ADMINISTRATION BRANCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I HAVE WITH ME MONEY
LIKE WAYNE OUR INTERIM DIRECTOR
FOR IT THE EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE
AND EUITY DIVISION I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. WHO
IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF. AB TWO
SIX NINE FOUR THE PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT MANY RESIGNATIONS FROM
TEACHERS WHICH HAS INTENSIFIED
THE PERSISTENT. SHORTAGE TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS
HAVE REPORTED HAVING MORE
TEACHER VACANCIES AND
DIFFICULTIES ATTRACTING NEW
TEACHERS THIS YEAR. IF TRISH IS
ESPECIALLY HIGH IN THE FIRST FEW
YEARS OF TEACHING IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF TEACHING. SEVERAL
STUDIES HAVE ESTIMATED THAT
BETWEEN 40% AND 50% OF NEW
TEACHERS LEAVE. WITHIN THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF ENTRY INTO
TEACHING. THERE ARE MANY HURDLES
TO BECOMING A TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA TRADITIONAL
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS FOR
CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO TO THREE
SEMESTERS AFTER COMPLETING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. TWO OF THE
SEMESTERS MUST BE SPENT DOING
UNPAID STUDENT TEACHING. FOR
MANY THIS OPTION IS VERY
CHALLENGING FROM A FISCAL
STANDPOINT. AFTER COMPLETING THE
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM NEW TEACHERS
ARE FACED WITH ADDITIONAL COSTS
RELATED TO REQUIRED ASSESSMENTS
AND CREDENTIALING FEES. ONCE
EXAMS AND FEES HAVE BEEN PAID BY
THE BEGINNING TEACHER NEW
TEACHERS MUST THEN CLEAR THEIR
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL. THE
CLEAR THEIR PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIAL NEW TEACHERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN AN
INDUCTION PROGRAM. THE
TRADITIONAL TWO YEAR INDUCTION
PROGRAM COST APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AB TWO SIX NINE FOUR WOULD
REMOVE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
THOUSANDS OF NEW TEACHERS IN
NEED OF CLEARING THEIR
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL. OR WHO
STILL NEED TO COMPLETE THEIR
TEACHING PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
AND OR THE READING INSTRUCTION
COMPETENCE YES ASSESSMENT. THIS
LEGISLATION IS A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARD ADDRESSING THE FISCAL
CHALLENGES THAT IMPACTS OUR
TEACHER WORK FOR SHORT SHORTAGE
IN CALIFORNIA. WORKING CLOSELY
WITH CTC ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
AGAIN- A SIMPLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO FOR THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND TO THIS
COMMITTEE I HOPE YOU CAN SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS. OKAY GREAT I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES AT A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT- ANY
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION WERE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OR THE COMMITTEE DO
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER BENNETT
MOVES. THE ONLY SECONDS- BUT IT
COMES REALLY COMMITTEE MEMBER
SINGLE CONCERT OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH AND I AGAIN THE
COMMITTEE- DOES A LOT OF REALLY
HARD WORK I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THEY'VE DONE I
KNOW. I ONLY MY TWO BILLS THAT
WERE CHALLENGING FOR YOU I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE SO I WOULD THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF THAT WORK AND I
THINK YOU. MISTER DONALD FOR
INDULGING ME AND- BUT- ALL OF
THESE BILLS APPRECIATED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT.
OUT RIGHT. THANK YOU. THIS CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FOUR. THE
MOTION IS THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. I
DON'T KNOW WHY DALLI. DALLI EYES
BENNETT. BENNETT I. CHEN CHEN I
LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. IT IS SIX MODE SO
IT IS OUT THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA MISTER
MCCARTY WAY MR LEE. HE'S GOT ONE
MORE. IF YOU ARE READY. WHO.
LET'S GO WOOD MISTER MCCARTY IS
GONNA- PRESENTED VIOLIN NUMBER
TWENTY TWENTY YES AB TWENTY FIVE
OH SEVEN MISTER MCCARTY MAY
PERCEIVE AND READY THANK YOU
LAST TIME DOWN HERE I THIS IS A
BILL RELATE TO OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US I THIS IS AN
ISSUE FOLLOWING UP WITH WITH
LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC A STATE
BUDGET WHICH SET A PATH FOR
UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA THIS JUST MAKE
SURE THAT MONIES ARE PROPERLY
SPENT AND FOCUSING ON QUALITY-
WE KNOW THAT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE GREATER
ACADEMIC SUCCESS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL. A LOWER
RATES OF SIX BUT SUSPENSION
EXPULSION AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
BE INVOLVED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ENGAGE IN
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ESPECIALLY CRITICAL TO REACH
YOUTH ARE WHO ARE- AT RISK IN
DISADVANTAGED NEIGHBORHOODS TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL ACADEMIC
SUPPORT AND RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES TO KEEP YOU ENGAGED
HOWEVER THE VAST MAJORITY OF
STATE FUNDING FORAFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IS THAT COURT IS
DEDICATED FOR PROGRAMS FOR OUR
YOUNGEST STUDENTS LEAVING OUT
OLDER STUDENTS WHO WOULD
STRONGLY BENEFIT FROM THESE
PROGRAMS. IF LESS THAN 3% OF
LAST YEAR'S AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING
IN IN YEARS PAST WITH DEDICATED
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. A FURTHER
LAST YEAR'S ONE BILLION ONGOING
INVESTMENT FOR THE UNIVERSAL FOR
SCHOOL AND THE FOUR BILLION
OPPOSED. THE BUDGET FROM THE
GOVERNOR R. FOUR EIGHT THREE
SIX- THIS PROTECTS ACCESS FOR
QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
FOR. YOUTH IN MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL BY EARMARKING A PORTION
OF THE EXISTING AFTER SCHOOL
FUNDING FOR YOUTH IN GRADES
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE. I WITH ME
TODAY ARE. JENNIFER DIETRICH
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
GENEVIEVE. KERNS UPPER. WHICH
SET UP THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES
. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA
DONNELLA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE
KONIG CHAU FAIR AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF GENERATION THAT WE
ARE A STUDENT LED ADVOCACY GROUP
FOCUSED ON EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
AND WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
AB TWO FIVE OH SEVEN. AT JOHN UP
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEARNING AND
FOR GROWTH. QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM PROVIDE A SAFE AND
ENGAGING PLACE TO PROMOTE THE
PHYSICAL SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
ACADEMIC GROWTH OF STUDENTS OF
ALL AGES. AND MANY OF THE
BENEFITS OF AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPACTFUL FOR USE IN MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL. AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS OFFER AVENUES TO
COLLEGE AND THE WORKPLACE I
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP AND USE
TECHNOLOGY. BY PROMOTING CROSS
CULTURAL UNDERSTANDING
COLLABORATIVE THINKING AND
LEADERSHIP SKILLS. AND RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE
GREATER ACADEMIC SUCCESS CAREER
PREPARATION AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAN THOSE WHO DO
NOT PARTICIPATE. MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO REGULARLY
PARTICIPATE IN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ALSO REPORT GREATER
SCHOOL CONNECTEDNESS ACADEMIC
MOTIVATION AND CARING ADULTS
RELATIONSHIPS. IS CRUCIAL
BENEFITS KEEPING YOUTH ENGAGED
IN SCHOOL WHICH IS MORE THAN
EVER MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER IN
THE WAKE OF COVERT NINETEEN
WHICH RESULTED IN DRAMATIC
DECREASES IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE
AND ENGAGEMENT. JENNIFER PLOTS
THE STATE'S MONUMENTAL
INVESTMENTS IN UNIVERSAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. UNIVERSAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WILL PROMOTE
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD
ACCESS TO THE SAME AFTER SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES ENRICHMENT AND
ACADEMIC SUPPORT AS THEIR MORE
AFFLUENT PEERS. HOWEVER THE
ENTIRETY OF THE STATE'S PLAN
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL IS
PRIORITIZE FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS. CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS DESERVE
TO HAVE A SAFE AND RICH IN PLACE
AFTER SCHOOL HOURS WHERE THEY
CAN DEVELOP SKILLS AND
RELATIONSHIPS I WILL HELP THEM
SUCCEED IN SCHOOL CAREER AND
LIFE. BY PRIORITIZING A PORTION
OF EXISTING AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS IN MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL AB TWO FIVE ZERO SEVEN
WILL ENSURE THE OLDER YOUTH
MAINTAIN ACCESS TO THESE
BENEFICIAL PROGRAMS. AS THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN UNIVERSAL
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS GROW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAN DIETRICH ON BEHALF
OF THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH. THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND
STRESS AMONG STUDENTS LAST WEEK
THE CDC WARNED OF ACCELERATING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AMONG
ADOLESCENTS WITH MORE THAN FOUR
IN TEN TEENS REPORTING THAT THEY
FEEL QUOTE PERSISTENTLY SAD AND
HOPELESS. AND ONE IN FIVE TEENS
SAYING THEY'D KOMPLETT
CONTEMPLATED SUICIDE. WE KNOW
THAT STUDENT SUCCESS IN SCHOOL
AND LIFE HINGES ON THE SUPPORT
OF CARING AND EFFECTIVE ADULTS
GETTING CALIFORNIA FOUR IN TEN
HIGH SCHOOL FRESHMAN. CAN'T
IDENTIFY A CARING RELATIONSHIP
WITH AN ADULT ON CAMPUS. AS YOU
ALL KNOW SCHOOL COMMUNITIES ARE
ALSO STRUGGLING WITH A DRAMATIC
DECREASE IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE
AND ENGAGEMENT AFTERSCHOOL AND
SUMMER LEARNING PROGRAMS BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AND CARE WITH
CARING AND SUPPORTIVE ADULTS
PROVIDE SAFE SPACES WHERE
STUDENTS CAN BUILD CONFIDENCE
AND FEEL A SENSE OF BELONGING.
IN CONNECTS COOLS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. IRAN'S ALSO PROVIDE
ACADEMIC AND VOCATIONAL AND
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES TO HELP
KEEP YOU INVESTED AND GROWING
AND AS THEY'VE ALREADY SAID THE
RESEARCH SHOWS. YOU KNOW
INCREASE IN ATTENDANCE MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL
LOWER RATES OF SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSIONS LESS LIKELY TO
BECOMING INVOLVED IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO INCREASE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAN ADOLESCENTS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING LEFT OUT DUE TO
THE LACK OF FUNDING ONLY 25% OF
HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
PUBLIC FUNDING FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AND AS ALREADY STATED
THE STATE'S FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN EXPANDING AFTER
SCHOOL AND SUMMER PROGRAMS
LEAVES OUT MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS NOT A PENNY IS
PRIDE PRIORITIZED FOR THEM. AB
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN PRIORITIZES
FEDERAL AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING FOR
HIGH SCHOOL MIDDLE SCHOOL YOUTH
IN FUTURE GRANT COHORTS AND
ENSURES THAT THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF STATE FUNDING FOR MIDDLE. FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOL YOUTH CANNOT BE
REDUCING FUTURE COHORTS. LIKE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS NEED ACCESS
TO THE SAFE PLACES TO BUILD
THOSE SKILLS AND THOSE CRITICAL
RELATIONSHIPS AT SCHOOL SO THEY
CAN SUCCEED IN SCHOOL LIFE AND
CAREER. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS DONNA
HOFFMAN CULLEN AND REPRESENTING
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS AND
COUNCIL FIRST ON AMERICAN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE NATIONAL
MAP OF THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH YMCA SAN DIEGO
ARKAN EDUCARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AS YOU KNOW FOR THE SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. NO
OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS READY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION. MISTER BENNETT MOVES
MISTER LEAST SECONDS- YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT LAST. GROUP WHO
TESTIFIED ON BEHALF OF- LAW
ENFORCEMENT JUST REMINDS US
THAT- WHAT KIDS A STATIC TROUBLE
SAY THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
RESEARCH SHOWS AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS MATTER. AND SO THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE TRYING
TO FORWARD AND- CONTINUES AND
EXPANDS FUNDING FOR OUR OLDER
KIDS SAID WITH THAT ASK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU. VERY THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY BUSY KIDS A TIRED KID
A TIRED KIDS GOOD GOOD RIGHT.
WITH THAT- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB TWENTY FIVE
OH SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
DONNA HI DOLLY. ALII SENATE
SENATE AYE CHAN CHAN I BELIEVE
WE AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. S. SIX VOTES THANK
YOU THIS OUT SO THAT WE WILL
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU MISTER LATE. WE WERE
LATE AND HAVE YOUR YOU DO HAVE
IT NOW. HIS CHECK AND- MISTER
LAY. WHO'S GOT FILE ITEMS.
SEVENTEEN I AM I AM SEVENTEEN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WESTERLY
ASSEMBLY BRIEF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS FIRST ARE THEY
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND I AM
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL SIMPLY
ESTABLISH PARITY BETWEEN
BUILDING STANDARDS FOR SCHOOL
RESTROOMS BEING RENOVATED THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON
SCHOOL RESTROOMS ARE NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED WHEN RECEIVING STATE
FUNDING FOR THESE FOR THESE
INNOVATIONS IN THE STATE WHILE
ROLLS ALONG LASSEN DROUGHTS
REQUIRING RENOVATION PROJECTS TO
MEET THE SAME CAL GREEN
STANDARDS AS NEWLY TRACTOR
RESTAURANTS AND HAVING OUR
PLUMBING FIXTURES BE AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE WELL SINCE
WITH ACHIEVING OUR STATE'S WATER
CONSERVATION GOALS. THAT I AM
PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY A
WITNESS AND SUPPORT EATEN TAMMY
WHO IS ELEVENTH GRADER AT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO'S
WEST CAMPUS. GOOD AFTERNOON IS
THE MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ETHAN TAM
AND I AM CURRENTLY A JUNIOR AT
WEST CAMPUS HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I AM HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AS THE CURRENT REGION TO
PRESIDENT. TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
SUPPORT AND- TO DEMONSTRATE
SUPPORT AND SPONSORING THIS BILL
. THE BRIEFLY REITERATE THE
FALLEN BILL. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN IT REQUIRES THE GOVERNING
BOARD. OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
INCLUDE AS PART OF A
MODERNISATION PROJECT FAUCET
AERATORS AND WATER CONSERVING
PLUMBING FIXTURES IN ALL
BATHROOMS WHEN APPLYING FOR
STATE FUNDED PURSUANT TO THE
GREEN ACT FOR A SCHOOL
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. PRESCHOOL
FACILITY CONSTRUCTED BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. AT MY OWN SCHOOL THE
INTERIOR OF OUR BATHROOMS HAVE
NOT BEEN FULLY RENOVATED- THOUGH
WE HAD MINOR RENOVATIONS MADE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. A. S. UST
REPORT FOUND THAT OUR BATHROOMS
HAD NOT COMPLAINED FOSSE'S WHICH
AMONG OTHER COMPONENTS DO NOT A
PIPE WRAPS- PROPER AERATORS.
THIS MAKES THE WATER FREEZING
DURING THE WINTER AND PIPES
SUSCEPTIBLE TO EXTREME HOT AND
COLD WEATHER'S EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. THIS
BECOMES A TRUE INCONVENIENT FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF ALIKE EXTREME
TEMPERATURES IN EITHER DIRECTION
CONSTRAIN THE PLUMBING
POTENTIALLY LEADING TO LEAKY ARE
BURSTING PIPES AND AN OVERALL
WASTAGE OF WATER GREATLY
AFFECTING THE WATER SUPPLY IN
OUR STATE. CALIFORNIA'S WELL
KNOWN FOR ITS DROUGHT DILEMMA
EVERY YEAR WE ARE STUCK WITH THE
SAME NARRATIVE OF THE STREET THE
THAT THE STATE IS STRUGGLING
WITH THE DROUGHT. AS THE WORLD
MOVES FOR CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
BECOME A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE HAVE
WE IMPACT AND HOW WE TREAT OUR
PRECIOUS WATER. EACHCOMING YEAR
THE ISSUE ON WHO AND WHERE WOULD
RECEIVE WATER BECOMES MORE
DIFFICULT AND INTENSE. CURRENTLY
THE STATE IS ALLOCATING WATER
VERY PRECISELY TO ENSURE THAT NO
WATER GOES TO WASTE. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WHAT HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THIS PRESSURE BY
INSTALLING OR RENOVATING
RESTROOMS IN SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE TO BE MORE WATER EFFICIENT
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY. IT
IS TRULY IMPORTANT THAT WE
MANAGE OUR WATER COULD
CONSCIOUSLY AND PRACTICE GOOD
HABITS THAT WILL HAVE POSITIVE
IMPACTS. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
SIGNIFICANCE CANNOT BE MEASURES
MEASURED ADDED AS IT WILL HELP
SCHOOLS BE MORE COGNIZANT OF THE
GROWING ISSUE OF OUR WATER
CRISIS. WHILE ALSO HELPING
SCHOOLS MODERNIZE OUTDATED AND
DILAPIDATED BATHROOMS THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS BELT AND MAKE
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. AGAIN WELL
DONE- WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY OPPOSITION IN
OPPOSITION- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
MR MCCARTY SECOND B MISTER
BENNETT- LOOKS LIKE THERE'S NO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OF THOROUGH
JOB WELL DONE I WITH THAT- YOU
MAY CLOSE RECKLESS DRIVER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
DONALD I THOUGHT I'D- DALLI.
DALLI I'D SENATE. SENATE AYE
CHAN CHEN I LIED HI LEAI MCCARTY
. MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA. IT
HAS SIX MODE SO IT IS OUT THANK
YOU. WITH THAT- JUST PEOPLE
COULD FOLKS REMAINS SEATED JUST
FOR A MOMENT WE HAVE TO DO THE-
AND SEND CALENDAR.
M. AND QUIET. WITH A PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE NEED A MONSTER WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND IS PROMOTE
MOVE BY MR DOLLARS SECOND AYE MR
CHAN. THE STUDY. WITH THE STORY
AND MR CHAN. I THANK CALENDAR-
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY OR NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY FIVE OH ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWO THREE THREE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS.
TO THE FLOOR. O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW WHY DALLI. DALLI II
BENNETT. BENNETT I'D CHEN CAN I
LEAVE LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. THAT'S A THAT'S SIX
VOTES. WHAT IS OUT WITH THAT WE
HAVE A. IF ANYONE WISHES TO ADD
ON. YOU WANT TO GO THROUGH THESE
DATA. IN. AND OF THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED. ANOTHER THE ADDAMS.